Tim Maudlin is a professor at NYU a
visiting professor at Harvard and
Carnegie Mellon as well as an
influential philosopher of science
specializing in the metaphysical
foundations of physics and logic today
we discuss various interpretations of
quantum mechanics including Bohemian
mechanics which is also known as pilot
wave theory we talk about super
determinism as well as how quantum
mechanics can be formulated without
observers also reformulations are the
foundations of physics without numbers
and also how to place time as Primal
rather than a derived notion or rather
than spatializing time which is what's
generally done next time with Tim we'll
also get to the Liars Paradox and
computation and Consciousness write down
your questions below because Tim will
most likely be coming on again for a
part two today's sponsor is brilliant if
you're familiar with toe you're familiar
with Brilliance but for those who don't
know Brilliance is a place where you go
to learn math science and engineering
through these bite-sized Interactive
Learning experiences for example and I
keep saying this I would like to do a
podcast on information Theory
particularly Chiara marleto which is
David Deutsch's student has a theory of
everything that she puts forward called
Constructor Theory which is heavily
contingent on information Theory so I
took their course on random variable
distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take Brilliance course it was the
first time that I could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive formula
that is to say that it would be
unnatural to Define it in any other
manner visit brilliant.org toe that is
t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and I recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons I think
you'll be greatly surprised that the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects you previously had a difficult
time grocking at some point I'll also go
through the courses and give a
recommendation in order thank you and
enjoy Professor I should let you know
that I'm extremely extremely excited to
speak with you you're one of the
brightest minds and most clear minds and
those don't go hand in hand usually
someone else that has those two
qualities is John bias Who's down to
Earth but extremely bright at the same
time reading his stuff yeah usually when
I interview someone they have one or two
distinctive ideas whereas for you I feel
like
I flip through your papers and there's
such a
a multitude it's like Douglas hofstetter
I'm gonna have to use this as an
introductory and hopefully you'll come
back on to speak about all of them what
is it about your work that's most
exciting parenthetically you can talk
about what that work is
um
well
I I because I'm in a philosophy
Department I have this uh amazing
freedom to pretty much look into
whatever I feel like looking into which
is why if you look through my work it's
covers a variety of different fields
um
most of my work has been in foundations
of physics although I have some other
stuff in semantics uh paper on
Consciousness and various other
philosophy of science topics
um
at the moment what's most exciting is is
some work I've been doing
for the last gosh five years
um which has gone in a direction I never
really anticipated
uh which is working on discrete geometry
and ways to
understand space and time as as having a
discrete rather The Continuous structure
and um
just within the last
six months or so I got to the point of
actually
having a structure
and doing some calculations and suddenly
finding uh relativity kind of falling
out into my lap from foundations
literature about as
unrelativistic as you could possibly
imagine so that's to me has been very
exciting whether it will go anywhere at
the end of the day or not I don't know
but it um
if nothing else it's an illustration
that's
relativistic structure May emerge in a
very natural way from a foundation that
looks completely unrelativistic so that
to me has been quite exciting
um so that's what I've been doing most
recently I mean there's some other
things trying to get trying to get
numbers out of physics I I don't like
having numbers in physics so I've been
trying to get rid of them and I made
some progress on that
um
a variety thank you okay you're gonna
have to elaborate on that last Point
well okay so I can say some things very
simply
um
if you go back to ancient Greece which
is always a nice place to go back to and
ancient Greeks mathematics was divided
into two sub-disciplines
arithmetic and geometry and arithmetic
was a theory of numbers and of course
through the Greeks the numbers
are well what we would normally say what
we would call the counting numbers right
the positive integers although in a way
the numbers for the Greeks started with
two not with one
which is as I like to point out also the
way we talk right you know why
um because if if someone says if if
someone says do you do you have any pets
and I say yes I have a number of pets
the number is one yeah that's like a
joke right if I say I have a number of
pets you think I have at least two
um yeah I say I have a number of pets
and the number is zero then it's really
a bad joke right then you say you know
that just doesn't count as a number of
anything
um and and interesting we can't count
one is a number of things
um so you know if you just follow that
language you'd say yeah when you're when
you're talking about the numbers you're
talking about beginning with two that's
why one was very special for the Greeks
um one we all have a number of phds yeah
yeah exactly you know so it's not so
strange anyway so there was number
Theory and then there was there was
geometry which was the theory of of
continuous magnitudes of space basically
I mean and and between the two of them
the balance was very much on the side of
geometry I mean you had all of Euclid 13
books of Euclid with amazing proofs okay
you know proofs of of things you would
never imagine would even be true much
less provable
um and Euclid everybody knows Euclid not
that many people have heard of nicomicus
of Rhodes who was sort of the the top
guy in arithmetic
um and and that was the balance for uh
for a couple Millennia was that if you
look at math
it was it was the queen of of math was
geometry and number theory was kind of
um lower down and if you look at Newton
and Galileo and so on all of their
proofs are basically used the tools of
geometry
um
and what you notice is that is it if I
tell you the physical world has a
geometrical structure
that seems like a very natural thing to
say I mean geometry is a was thought to
be about the structure of space itself
and space itself is part of the physical
world
um
if I tell you the world has a numerical
structure it's not quite immediately so
clear what I could mean I mean people
it's reported that the pythagoreans who
love numbers said things like a horse is
the number 10 and you just go like what
in the world are you talking about
um you know how can a horse you know how
can a course be the number ten uh the
the connection
um between numbers I I think
it's a very good therapy
whenever you're looking at mathematical
physics and you've got algebraic
structure numerical structure to ask
yourself where it came from
because usually it's introduced by means
of some convention like by means of say
putting down a coordinate system and
assigning numbers as coordinates
and because that's not intrinsic to the
subject
they're an infinite number of ways to do
that and then you have to be very
careful about
what in your representation is a mere
artifact of the of the conventions and
what corresponds to something that's
really there
um this is the kind of thing Einstein
says I mean the the reason it took him
10 years to get from special relativity
to general relativity and he says this I
think in the autobiography in the in the
show volume
is that he kept thinking that the
coordinates had to have some physical
significance
and and it took him a long time to
understand that they don't and in order
to have a mathematical
structure that's capable of handling
curved space time
it has to be there are no special
coordinate systems right in a flat space
Cartesian coordinates are special and in
a flat space time where rents
coordinates are special
and you tend to only use them and
they're very convenient in a curve space
in a variably curved space there are no
special coordinate systems and you
you're really confronted with the fact
that the coordinate values don't mean
anything by themselves and then you have
to think hard about what does mean
something right what are the quantities
that really characterize the space
itself
um so you know it there's an interesting
history here it starts actually with
Descartes among people in in La geometry
where he introduces not what we would
call Cartesian coordinates but he's very
clear because
and I'm sorry to be going on so long but
you still no it's fine please
um you know it was known from the Middle
Ages and especially the Arabic Scholars
that if you're doing number Theory
then you can do use algebraic methods to
solve problems and that the algebraic
methods were really powerful
and so what Descartes asked himself is
huh I wonder if there's a way that I can
somehow use algebra to solve geometry
problems
and what he was interested in was was
doing that he's very clear about what
he's doing and in fact one of the things
he realizes is that in numbers when
you're dealing with numbers one is a
special number right it's the only
number that squares to itself besides
zero
um it's the only number that when you
multiply it by anything else you get the
same thing back so one is just picked
out
from the algebraic structure as really
special but when you're doing geometry
there's no unit that's special there's
no length that's special so Descartes
realized that in order to convert
geometrical problems into algebraic ones
he had to arbitrarily choose a unit
um which is really important
and is this overcome with a fine spaces
rather than just a vector space well it
it was look he's doing in a Continuum I
mean his interest in Geometry or in a
continuum
and no link is special on a Continuum I
mean you've got all these lines the the
other thing that's that's that is worth
noting is that if you're dealing with
numbers what part of what makes
something a number field why we even
call a set of objects numbers at all is
that you can multiply them and when I
multiply two numbers I get another
number
but there's no there's no corresponding
geometrical operation
if I give you two magnitudes if I give
you two line segments say
there's no operation corresponding to
multiplication that will hand me back
another line segment the best you can do
in a euclidean space you can make an
area right you can make a rectangle
um but the rectangle is a different kind
of thing I mean the the units in which
you characterize it are different than
than the lengths so there's no natural
object that corresponds to
multiplication in geometry
but we use multiplication all the time
in doing physics because we've converted
everything into numerical
representations right just to be clear
let me just see if I'm breaking it down
correctly if you don't mind so when you
say hey if we have two lengths or two
line segments it's not obvious how to
multiply them right so someone may say
well can you add them you can add the
lengths okay you can add the lengths
yeah
and then they may think well no I can
multiply well you think you have some
way of multiplying let me tell you this
first line segment was actually the
number one so your way of multiplying
actually doesn't change it so you think
hey I did some complex and then I could
just say no this first line was number
two so that's why you say that there
needs to be a unit picked out in order
to multiply when you're thinking about
line segments well it's not it's not
just which comes first I mean certainly
multiplication should be an operation
that commutes it shouldn't matter what
order I I give them to you the real
problem is
um the number one is the multiplicative
unit so when I multiply
any other number by one I get the same
number back again
and and there's no geometrical length
that's picked out as special
um that's why that's why Descartes says
in order to convert a geometrical
problem into an algebraic one I have to
make an arbitrary choice of unit I'm
going to say oh this length counts as
one
if I do that then I can define something
that you would call multiplication right
not now suppose I have this special
length that I've just picked out of the
air I oh that's length one
now I give you two other links A and B
and then you make a rectangle out of a
and b
which has an area and now you say well
if I want another rectangle with the
same area but one of the sides is the
unit
this arbitrary unit how long does the
other side have to be
and then that will give me a length
but it's only relative to the choice of
that unit if I choose choose a different
unit I'll get a different one so how are
you going to create all of this richness
of standard multiplication and addition
using geometry
um you you don't you don't try to to
replicate
the thing about multiplication
is that again it's a function that takes
two numbers as input and gives you a
number back as output so I can just
iterate and multiply and re-multiply and
Cube and so on
um the the proper
operation in Geometry if I give you two
lengths
is it I can construct something out of
it but what I construct out of it is not
a length it's a surface and if I give
you a surface in another length I can
construct a volume
and if I only have three dimensions I'm
done right because if you now give me
another length there's nothing I can do
if it's a four-dimensional space okay I
could make a hyper volume and if it's
five dimensional space and so on but um
I a lot of what happens
in physics
uh you don't go up above the
dimensionality of the space and so
basically what I've been playing with
which is I think uh
I don't know if it's an original idea
but it's certainly not one that's been
much investigated is something I call
full discrete geometry and the full
means
you have Zero Dimensional things points
you have one dimensional Atomic things
you can think of as lines you have two
dimensional Atomic things Atomic
surfaces you three-dimensional Atomic
things Atomic volumes okay and if it's a
three-dimensional space then you've got
those things to play with
um
and so you can't just keep whereas if
you have numbers again I can just take a
number and multiply it by itself and
then again and then again and then again
and then again as many times as I want
and I'll still have a number I never you
know the multiplication operation
can be it's a binary operation but it
extended to any to multiplying any any
number of numbers right any final
numbers
there's no way that when you multiply
outside of the dimension so it should
jump out but instead it goes back to the
beginning no no it's just not it's just
not a defined operation because the
operation again the the the the
operation is one that for example can
take two one-dimensional elements and
give you back a two-dimensional element
and it can take a one-dimensional
element in a two-dimensional element and
give you back a three-dimensional
element but if you give it something
else it can't give you anything back
because there are no four-dimensional
elements or five dimensional right so it
just doesn't have you know it's not that
it recycles back or anything it's just
not a defined operation
now when you say that there are no
four-dimensional nor five-dimensional
which means in the theory that you're
constructing what you would like would
to be to in this manifest image of
three-dimensional space you want to get
back to that rather than say something
that's a bit more outrageous or unproven
or right no I mean look the formal
Theory can handle four-dimensional
spaces five dimensional spaces a million
dimensional spaces right 11 dimensional
space you want to do String Theory it's
not that the it's not that the formal
apparatus is limited
but
you're you'd make a decision okay I'm
going to look at two-dimensional
geometry or I'm going to look at
three-dimensional geometry I'm going to
look at 12 dimensional gear all right
right and once you make that decision
then you're limited within that scope
let me just lay out some thoughts so
firstly you make a reference to number
there by saying three-dimensional or
four-dimensional and this is strange
because you're trying to build a world
without numbers but then we need a
number in order to specify this world so
how does that work so that that works
because the the Greek numbers the
counting numbers are perfectly fine if
you've got something to count right it's
not that I it's not that I hate all
numbers
um if okay I can say there are two
chairs in the room because you know I'm
just counting one two
um but what happened historically of
course if you want to convert geometry
into arithmetic you need more than the
counting numbers
and if you look back at the history of
it it's very interesting
um the Greeks really only recognized
officially the positive integers as
numbers then you can push a little and
try and convince people there are these
things that you call rational numbers
and that had a little bit of resistance
to it but not too bad then well you
could there are two things you have to
do you eventually have to go to the
irrational numbers if you want to do
euclidean geometry that had a lot of
resistance to it right there are people
who said no those don't make any sense
because if I try and express them in
decimal form it goes on forever it gets
lost in infinity and and then you also
need the negative numbers which you know
there were people who were very upset
about that and you can see why right I
mean you said look okay I understand
what you mean when you say you have two
sheep I understand what you mean even
when you say you have zero sheep but
what would it be to have negative two
sheep right right
um there there can't be less than zero
so negative numbers and it's just in the
record in the historical record there
was a lot of resistance to negative
numbers
so I don't have any problem with
integers if you have something to count
and and the counting measure in this
discrete geometry you use counting
measure because you have a finite number
of points or a finite number of lines or
a finite number of surfaces in a certain
situation and you can just count them
and the counting is important so it's
not that I hate all numbers
I just when you use numbers you should
ask yourself okay where are the numbers
coming from if they're coming from
Counting something discrete okay that's
a good answer
if they're not
then you need a fancier story about why
you're using them at all let's get
quickly philosophical if you don't mind
and then I want to get to your views on
quantum mechanics there's different
theories of Truth so there's
correspondence coherence and pragmatism
are the main three
for the correspondence this just made me
think well in the correspondence theory
of Truth could there be minus two
because minus two wouldn't correspond to
something of the world but then it seems
strange because many people who say I
believe in the correspondence theory of
Truth are perfectly fine using numbers
real numbers I never thought about that
what does the correspondence theory of
Truth have to say about
real numbers or even complex numbers
well okay so the the I think the
difficulty you're having is that you're
touching on an extremely
extremely difficult subject
um and one about which I don't have much
to say because it's too deep for me and
that's the ontology of mathematics
that's mathematical reality
so if I'm a if I'm in some intuitive
sense a correspondence theorist
I say look at least for certain
sentences
what makes that sentence either true or
false is whether it correctly or
incorrectly describes some
non-linguistic thing right the subject
matter
and for physics the subject matter is
the physical world so we kind of know at
least what the target is but but
mathematical items as as Plato pointed
out are not physical items
so if you want to be a basically a
correspondence theorist as I do you're
naturally going to be a platonist in
mathematics which I am right that is I
am I I think they're mathematical truths
and if you ask what makes them true the
answer is well mathematical reality and
if you ask me what mathematical reality
is I'm going to say well it isn't
physical reality for sure
um
it has its own kind of existence very
much the way Plato would say and there
are facts about it and some of the facts
we can discover and some of them will
never discover is girdle assures us
um okay that's fine there's a world that
has more facts about it than we're able
to to to to just it's kind of amazing we
can discover anything about it you know
I shouldn't be very surprised I can't
discover everything about it
um so
what what you're really asking from my
point of view is not about the physical
world at all it's about the nature of
purely mathematical reality
and again I I very firmly believe there
is such a thing and and it's independent
of physical reality right I mean physics
could have come out all kinds of
different ways but however physics came
out it wouldn't change the mathematical
facts at all so physics is dependent on
the mathematical reality but not vice
versa no well no physics is not
dependent on mathematical reality in a
white physics see mathematical physics
is a discipline
that uses mathematical items
to attempt to describe the physical
world
and the mathematical items exist they
are what they are and they are what they
are independently of what we think and
we can find out about them by you know
in a math department you can investigate
the structure of the mathematical items
the Deep question
which is always there is why should
these mathematical items serve as good
representations of physical reality
now this is where I would say
again for many numbers I'm puzzled white
why why am I using numbers anyway for
certain geometrical things again purely
abstract mathematical geometrical things
it seems to me perfectly plausible to
say Well they're good because the
physical world literally has a
geometrical structure
um you know Newton thought that space
was a three-dimensional euclidean how do
you three-dimensional euclidean space
structure and it could have had it turns
out not to have but it could have had
and if it did have then you'd perfectly
well understand why euclidean geometry
which remains a perfectly good
mathematical
investigation into euclidean's Pace you
would understand why it has so much
utility for physics
um three-dimensional euclidean geometry
right I mean 10 dimensional euclidean
geometry exists just as well abstractly
as three-dimensional euclidean geometry
but it might have no use in physics
because actual physical space is not 10
dimensional
when I think about platonism I think of
it as being extremely mystically
religious and I don't have any I don't
score in it for being so and I think
Plato thought of the forms of something
mystical as well something related to
God I can ask your thoughts on that but
what I wanted to say was more about it's
strange because you were saying that the
physical reality doesn't depend on the
mathematical However the fact that we
can use it it gives some visual analogy
it's as if we're these physical beings
and we can reach into the closet of
mathematics and pull out something and
then use it as a tool here
it doesn't seem like the mathematics
reaches into us and then uses it there
although perhaps it doesn't we don't
know so it seems like
that's a world that we pull from now how
can we so is there an interaction
between these two worlds quite there's a
huge turn in Plato the the turn between
the early and the middle dialogues which
is indicated in in meno
and in Nino is where you you have a kind
of standard Socratic
dialogue cross-examining Nino and
showing that he doesn't really know what
virtue is what arate is and then he gets
all messed up and says I have nothing
more to say and Socrates says well why
don't we keep talking
Amino quite reasonably says wait a
minute you tell me you don't know what
virtue is and I now don't know what
virtue is why should we keep discovering
we're too ignoramuses why should we keep
with each other and and Socrates says
well you know and then he kind of
indicates the theory of reminiscence but
the important point is he then brings
out this mathematical question
um if I have a square
say two units on a side so it's four
square it's area is four square units
and I want to build a double square that
is one whose area is twice as big eight
units
um
along which what line do I build it
so that's a perfectly good question and
he brings this slave over who's not
learned any geometry and the slave
starts out
saying oh you double the side and then
he points out they do some counting and
say no that's not right that gives me
16. then he says well let's try three
well that doesn't work that gives me not
and then the slave says I don't know
right and then Socrates draws in you
know the diagonals and and again they
just count and easily show that the
square on the diagonal has twice the
area now I don't think the thing in the
world mystical about it's the opposite
of mystical right mystical suggests some
kind of inarticulable
presentation
that you believe without reason
right and this is just the opposite the
reason you believe that the square on
the diagonal has twice the area is
you've got a proof
right that's what you could gives you
he's not a Mystic right Euclid's not a
Mystic he's a guy who can prove it
so you know and that's what's
interesting I mean the thing that
interested Plato is look I can actually
literally know things about geometrical
figures know them have proofs of them
have demonstrations know what the truth
is and he says in timeus
which is the closest he comes to giving
us a physics
paimaeus does uh he says look don't
expect that kind of knowledge of the
physical world the best you can expect
of the physical world is what he calls
an echos logos which is a plausible
story right a likely account a plausible
story and I'll give you a plausible
story but I can't prove that it's right
um so Plato just recognized correctly
that we have much better epistemic
access
more secure epistemic access
to mathematics than we do to physics and
that's not because he's a Mystic it's
it's the opposite he's kind of a hyper
rationalist
okay so two thoughts and I don't know if
this is apocryphal or not but Pythagoras
at least repeatedly said that there is
something ill about the square root of
two no you didn't I'm sorry
okay so at least infamously infamously
or reputed yeah this is a this is a fake
story interested in the truth here
there's a wonderful book called The
mathematics of Plato's academy by Donald
Fowler
um
which goes through all this that this
whole that the pythagoreans were really
um yeah there's a lot of propag
anti-pythagorean propaganda it's it's
actually quite unclear in the historical
record what the pythagoreans believed
but what is clear is that nobody was
worried about the square root of well
again let me even be more precise
when we say
there was an issue about the square root
of two we mean by the square root of two
a number
let's go back again right
1.414. yeah
the Greeks did not recognize the
existence of any such number they didn't
believe there was any number which if
you multiplied it by itself you got two
why because they thought the numbers
were the were the counting numbers and
obviously you can't
square and you can't multiply any
counting number by itself and get two
now what they did recognize by a very
interesting geometrical proof is that if
you have a square
and you have its side and you have its
diagonal that those are in commensurable
that is that the length of one cannot be
expressed as a ratio in terms of the
length of the other
now that doesn't pick out the diagonal
as the bad guy or the side is the square
bad guy in commensurability of that sort
is a is a relation between two lengths
it doesn't say oh you know the side is
good and the diagonal is bad or anything
like that it just says
these the ratio of lengths between the
side and the diagonal does not
correspond to the ratio between any two
integers that's what they knew
but it didn't seem to bother them
um in fact they thought it was quite
interesting there was a whole there was
a a um a whole terminology about all
about links that are all logon
which would be like these that can't be
expressed in terms of ratios and and
they had further subdivisions among them
and nobody was upset about it
just an interesting fact
what led you down this route of trying
to make geometry Primal like underived
elements of reality
just mostly the thought that I could
understand I could I could see how
a geometrical representation could in
principle more or less directly
correspond to the structure of the world
that the world the physical world sorry
that the physical world could literally
have a geometrical structure
and I don't understand how the physical
world could literally have an algebraic
structure
so I I'd like to get along as much as I
can with geometry this word geometry is
interesting when I was in university I
always thought of geometry as I forgot
the exact name but I took some course
where it's almost like euclidean
geometry or it is euclidean geometry and
there was inversions I had to do some
problem with inversions this is all I
remember what is that called analytic
geometry is there some word for it like
planar geometry something like that I
mean I I'm yeah I'm not exactly sure
okay well anyway it's with what you
construct with lines and circles and
then there's differential geometry and
to me I see that as extremely algebraic
firstly it's also contingent on the real
numbers
differential geometry is basically what
you use when the geometrical structure
changes from place to place so in
euclidean Geometry you have all these
nice symmetries right the the the the
the structure of euclidean space
is the same everywhere
so there's kind of translational
symmetries and it's the same in all
directions so they're rotational
symmetries right it's actually the same
even under expansions and contractions
which is really unusual that's not true
in in in even a space of uniform
curvature so it has all these nice
symmetries but you could be living in a
world where the geometry just doesn't
have these nice symmetries and then the
geometrical structure changes from place
to place and then you have to use
differential geometry which just means
that you you characterize the geometry
local in some little region and then in
the next one and then in the next one
with all these little overlapping maps
that cover the different regions and and
you don't have a constraint that the
geometry looks the same
in all the regions now none of that
suggests using numbers
and it doesn't you don't need to use
numbers I mean you numbers tend to get
in again with you when you introduce
coordinates but they're coordinate free
characterizations
of all of this of all of this geometry
so you don't need and as I said if the
space is curved then no coordinate
systems will be particularly great right
um the nice thing about a a spaces of
constant curvature and especially zero
curvature is that there are these nice
coordinate systems like Cartesian
coordinates so forgive me because it's
been a while since I've been in
University the way that I recall it is
that you define a smooth structure by
saying that so and so is infinitely
differentiable to Define
differentiability you have to say that
it goes from the reels to the reels I'm
sure you have some chart in between it's
like RN but somehow you have a curve
that's R to the m so R to the manifold
and then from the manifold down to a
chart so you require the reels here then
the reels on the chart and then you say
it's differentiable based on
differentiability in the reels I don't
know if that's correct please forgive me
if I'm incorrect no no that's the normal
way it's presented I mean what you said
is perfectly accurate is the way it's
taught that you throw in functions
from the space to the reels or the r to
the end
as part of the story yeah and and then
you talk you you you talk about whether
a function from RN to RN is continuous
and so on
um by appealing to the structure of the
real line that is the usual way it's
presented it doesn't have to be done
that way
and it should be obvious that there's
something quite artificial about it
because if I just have a space in front
of me
where's this function into the real
numbers coming from well it it only
comes by somehow laying down coordinates
which could be done in infinitely many
different ways
and choosing some arbitrarily
um and what you would prefer from as a
pure as a calculational matter
what they're doing is fine because it's
easier to calculate with numbers
as a conceptual matter you're better off
avoiding
this use of numbers where you can
because they're only introduced in a
kind of artificial way
so yeah I mean your your memory of that
is perfectly correct but people people
teaching math are not
I mean especially unless you really go
deep into the foundations of mathematics
they're teaching you a tool
um and when you learn calculus and
Vector calculus and so on they're giving
you a tool for doing calculations and
grinding out answers that's a very
effective tool
um what what happens if you're a
philosopher like me
is that
it's not so interesting learning how to
use the tool I mean when I when I was
doing my PhD in history and philosophy
of science because I was specializing in
physics I did was had to do graduate
level work in physics
and I took one course and I remember you
know perfectly fine horse Physics course
interesting for my purposes interesting
things were said on day one
the first day because it was on the
first day that the the professor was
trying to set up
what are we doing
and then the rest of the course which
was like how to use greens functions to
solve differential equations okay it
didn't matter to me I mean it just it
made no difference for my interests now
if you actually if I needed to get
numbers if I needed to actually grind
numbers out I really needed to
understand all the rest of that of
course but that's not what I do right
I'm more interested in well why am I
using numbers anyway
you know not how exactly do I use them
or or how do I solve these equations
right my only rarely once or twice in my
life if I had to actually solve an
equation to make progress
um
can you give me an instance of them of
the one or two times where you have to
use an equation oh yeah I mean I mean I
I mean I remember this very when my very
first book which is quantum non-locality
and relativity there's a
uh
there's a
a chapter which is about
part of it is about trying to mimic
non-locality violations of Bell's
inequality through a certain trick which
involves having uh particles or objects
that you're observing that just don't
show up that disappear that never show
up in the data okay and if you're very
clever
you can use this
Gap in the data
so that the data that does actually get
recorded will look like it violates
velvet's inequality even though nothing
non-local has happened
um and then there was a question that
arose which is well how efficient can
you be that is you you want to say I can
rule out this kind of trick if my
detectors
are have a certain efficiency all right
if my detectors are 100 efficient if
every time I throw a particle at a
detector it registers
then I can't use this trick because the
trick really depends upon there being
these missing data
uh but then you say okay well how how
exactly how much
Efficiency do I need before I can rule
out this loophole
and to answer that I had to actually
solve a differential equation which I
offhand I didn't quite know how to solve
I could write it down
um
and I I was actually I was in Croatia
off the peach I had a big yellow legal
pad and I had a little hand calculator
and I swear to God I sat there and and
numerically simulated an integral by
hand with this calculator uh until I got
it close enough to say hey that looks
like pi over 4.
and then once I saw that I said oh yeah
it is pi over four then I could work out
right how it goes uh how long ago was
that oh that was
gosh 30 years ago okay so this is before
wolf from alpha oh yeah oh yeah this is
this is before you were born
okay oh yeah okay so just to be clear
efficiency because I haven't heard that
term efficiency Houston I'm not an
experimentalist yeah my the worst course
in physics for me was the experimental
part I'm much more of a mathematical
person well let me see let me give it an
example when we see the double slit
experiment you see these Dots Dots Dots
Dots Dots Dots well sometimes
you throw out a photon and it just
doesn't register right it a DOT doesn't
click yeah and then you think okay well
well if it's not going to click it's not
going to click in some uniform manner so
the pattern that I eventually get this
oscillating pattern it is characteristic
of the photon but you're saying there
are some ways of designing an experiment
such that the missing data gives you a
pattern that's actually not there
there's a there's a way if if so if
you're an experimentalist there's just a
straightforward question how efficient
are my detectors right I have a beam and
I know how many particles on average are
coming through this beam and then I know
how many particles on average are being
detected by my detectors and there's
going to be a gap right I mean stuff
gets lost
um nothing is nothing is a hundred
percent efficient
um in my book I describe a certain trick
it's a very conspiratorial trick it's
not anything that would be physically
natural I mean the whole thing is kind
of crazy but you're just doing logically
possible
um there's a trick you can use if
there's high enough inefficiency in the
detectors
so that
the registered data
would violate the Bell inequality
without anything non-local and the trick
involves a very judicious and special
use of cases where data disappears right
where no data shows up so it never gets
into the recorded data
uh and
you can do that I mean it's not
conceptually it's not really hard to see
how it works at all
um
uh it's just
there's a price to pay you're you're
you're
you're
simulating by use of this trick
sending information where really no
information is being sent but you're
simulating it by use of this trick but
the more information you have to
simulate sending the more inefficient
the thing has to become
um you you have to more and more often
um uh use this trick of saying well uh
one of the particles is just going to
refuse to answer right I mean normally
you say I I take a particle and I send
it through a spin device and it's either
going to come out up or down but what if
the the particle has a third option
which is to just go mute and not give
you any answer at all and then get that
run gets deleted from the data
um it and so there's just a question of
how of what those numbers look like what
what is the
most
efficient way you can run that trick
because if you if your detectors then
have higher efficiency than that then
you can say well they can't be doing it
right you it's a loophole this there
were these kind of loopholes that people
talked about in tests of Bell's
inequality and the detector inefficiency
loophole was a big one for a long time
but they but you know generation after
generation of experimentalists just did
it better and better and better and got
higher and higher efficiencies and all
those loopholes have now been closed
okay experimentally closed sure sure
can't be the right answer
and you said that yours was
conspiratorial or do you mean contrived
the actual conditions
I mean it's it's like it's like the
electrons are out to trick us right I
mean it's a it the the the the the the
physical story
is not a natural one that anyone would
ever come up with you only come up with
it if you're sitting here saying I hate
non-locality I hate non-locality I want
some way to keep my physics local yet
consistent with the data that we have
and this is a trick which as long as the
data which you have there were certain
levels of detector and efficiencies it's
a trick you could use but there was
there's never a reason to believe it's
completely implausible physically
there's not no physical story behind it
it's just kind of looking well I could
you know this is possible this is
mathematically possible if I have enough
inefficiency to play with okay now let's
talk about quantum mechanics what I
noticed about you initially was I see
you as bringing some sober
reality to this whole realm of quantum
confusion and mysticism that generally
sells in magazines
spookiness strangeness other abnormal
qualities and then Bell's inequalities
generally sold as a trade-off between
non-locality and statistical
Independence or realism
so firstly is that the case and can you
tell the audience your view of what the
heck is going on Quantum mechanically
okay so uh all right yeah let me
let me start a little backwards here
this term realism has snuck into this
discussion and it really should just be
expunged
um
realism is not realism has nothing to do
with anything here in fact from a
philosophical point of view realism
scientific realism has to do with
epistemology doesn't have to do with
ontology with what there exists I mean
to say gosh
um
I can save I can save locality by just
giving up realism the way people say it
I often say oh yeah nothing actually
exists but thank God it's local I mean
it doesn't make any sense if you try and
Trace down people say oh Bell made some
Assumption of realism he made no such
assumption
there is no there's no assumption that
made that you can just deny and then
you're okay all right the actual theorem
of bell which I think is the most
important and astonishing result I mean
there's the mathematical theorem and
then the fact in the lab that these
inequalities are violated this is the
most astonishing thing in the history of
physics
and the theorem
as a piece of mathematics this is just a
comment about it as mathematics
is the theory every theorem you're
deriving something from some
suppositions
there are two suppositions there's one
that's called Bell locality it's the the
way that he expresses mathematically
what it would be if for a theory to be
local relativistically local meaning
that
there's no causation or effects that go
faster than light
that all of the events
that can count as a cause of something
happening lie in or on its past light
cone right nothing that would require
going faster than light and and in
addition it will be relevant for where
this goes nothing coming from the future
either I mean Bell's locality condition
also rules out reverse causation that
the future could could somehow cause
things in the present
so there's the locality condition
and then as a mathematical fact there's
a second condition that he uses in the
derivation which is called statistical
Independence
and from these two assumptions he
derives an inequality and says okay if
if any Theory
satisfies locality and satisfies
statistical Independence
then there are certain constraints on
the sorts of correlations you could
possibly see
in situations where Alice and Bob
are in their Labs doing experiments
so far away from each other that light
doesn't have time
to get from one lab to the other so
there couldn't be any any effects if all
effects had to go at most at the speed
of light
there couldn't be any effects from what
happens in Alice's lab on what happens
in Bob's or vice versa okay
so that's the theorem
and then you go in and you see this this
inequality I mean first of all you
notice that quantum mechanics predicts
violations of this inequality and then
you notice that you go in the lab and
check and quantum mechanics quantum
mechanical predictions are correct
um so you only had two suppositions from
which this follows locality and
statistical Independence so as a purely
logical matter you say well I have to at
least deny one or the other of these
um now
there are people who for reasons I do
not fathom I just literally don't
understand their reasons
are are so deeply committed to locality
that they're looking for any Escape
Route I mean that's more or less what we
were talking about with these with these
loopholes with these detection loopholes
right they don't like the idea of
non-locality and they're looking for any
Escape they can have
from from accepting it and these
detection loopholes for many years were
one until the experimentalists just
closed those loopholes they're gone
uh so the only other move pool is they
look at this and they say well I don't
want to deny locality I guess I have to
deny statistical Independence
and the problem with denying statistical
Independence is that it's kind of crazy
and it's it's crazy and conspiratorial
and on top of it you know as as you know
I've said and other people have said it
undermines
all scientific method I mean
if in order to get out of accepting
non-locality you deny
what's required assumptions that are
required to do science
that's not a good deal
right that's a really bad deal
speaking of that I sent you a video I'm
not sure if you had a chance to yeah
yeah I did okay so as a preface for
those who are watching the video is by
Sabine hostenfelder and it's on super
determinism either way I'll give a brief
description in the first 20 seconds or
so she says
some people think that if we do away
with statistical Independence then all
the science is undermined and she says
her attitude is no
so I'm curious to know your thoughts on
that firstly I am super determinism and
perhaps other specific comments were I
mean let me uh let me walk through this
although let me before because I knew
you were going to ask this let me just
point out to people because it's much
better than than listening to me if
you're interested in this be sure you
take
this book
John Bell's speakable and unspeakable in
quantum mechanics and very carefully
read
chapter 12
which is called free variables and local
causality
because Bell Nails it
completely
and any questions you have just he's
really
I mean Bell is an
extraordinarily precise
writer
he's not so good by the way if you watch
Sabina she talks about some interview he
gave and he's not so good in interviews
he sometimes slips up I would say
when he's talking off the top of his
head and says things which I think he
you know are just a bit sloppy and
uncharacteristic but when he writes
there are only a couple places it's an
entire book where I think he put a foot
wrong in what he writes well that's
everyone yeah I mean Comer nods I mean
everybody makes this case right we're
all making many more mistakes in real
time speech except everybody yeah and
and so if you're interested in this
topic and the the thing that amazes me
is I've had discussions with many people
who want to talk about super determinism
who've never read as far you know really
have never read this particular thing
which is the thing that Bell wrote about
it so three variables and local
causality and what I'm going to tell you
is basically what bell says
um
it has no and let's just start off by
saying this has nothing to do with free
will I mean all this talk about Free
Will has gotten into this discussion
from the beginning it was irrelevant
um the term super determinism is bad
because even as Sabina says you can't
get more deterministic than
deterministic okay
um
the the issue is is the mathematical
Assumption of statistical Independence
that's used in the theorem
now what is that assumption let me just
give you an example and why it's
important and why I say If you deny it
empirical science kind of goes out the
window
so suppose we're going to do a a test
and there are different experimental
conditions you might think of them as
experimental in control or in in our
case you're going to either set up a a
spin measuring device in the X direction
or the y direction or in some other
direction we have these different
um
conditions
and I'm doing tests and I'm doing tests
on a large number of items a large
number of rats or a large number of
particles or whatever
and I'm looking at statistics I'm
looking at at percentages
uh of the ones I experiment on with
these different conditions whether they
react this way or that way and when I'm
doing experiments on pairs on the
correlations between the two sides okay
now
what I do if I want to do just to take
the simple case everybody understands if
I want to check whether smoking causes
cancer in rats
I start out with a big group of rats
and then I want to subdivide it into an
experimental group in a control group
but I want to subdivide it in a way that
there's no bias between the two groups
the two groups
before I run the experiment are
statistically similar to each other
okay now there's some ways I can check
for that like if there are male rats and
female rats I can just kind of count
okay what percentage of Bale rats are in
this group and what percentage are in
this group and and I can make sure by
Distributing them that they have the
same percentages sure the thing is I
want the groups to be similar in all
respects even respects I'm completely
unaware of I mean maybe there's some
genes I don't know about
how do I do that well
I randomly assign
the rats to the two groups
this word random is important here the
word random here is absolutely important
what the word random there means it is
the condition that Bell uses of
statistical Independence it means that
the Sorting mechanism
does not is not biased or does not
respond or is not sensitive to the rats
okay so if I you you know you can
imagine flipping a coin for example I
mean that's a physical kind of what bell
would call a physical randomizer there's
there there are other randomizers I mean
he he uses this example which is very
nice because it takes all issues about
Free Will out of it he says look you
could use a pseudom a pseudo-random
number generator which works like this
start at the millionth digit of pi
and then output a one or a zero
depending upon whether the next digit is
even or odd all right so that'll give
you a sequence of ones and zeros that is
a pseudo-random sequence we call it
random because it will pass every
statistical test for Randomness you can
come up with
all right it'll be about the same number
of ones and zeros but there will be no
observable pattern
and you could use that and say okay for
one comes up then the rat goes this way
if a zero comes up it goes that way
now why do I do that because if the
Sorting is independent if whether the
rat went this way or that way is
independent of the of the nature of the
racks then with overwhelmingly high
probability that's calculable
each subgroup will be statistically like
the original group
if sixty percent of the rats had some
unknown feature in the original group
then 60 in each of the subgroups
will have that feature
and therefore the subgroups will be like
one another the really important thing
you want is you want the statistically
the subgroups to be like one another
and
that's why we use randomized procedures
for making these groups now if somebody
says now suppose I do this experiment
with the rats I take this big group I
randomly divide them by one of these
sorting mechanisms right by throwing
dice or by this sure randomizer whatever
into these two groups and then I expose
one to smoke and I treat the other the
same except I don't expose it to smoke
and then I see a lot more cancer in this
group then we infer that the smoke
caused cancer
now if somebody says no no no no really
what's going on is this some of the rats
were predisposed to get cancer no matter
what
and other the rats weren't and it just
turned out that the ones that were
predisposed got sorted over into the
ones into the smoke group and the ones
that weren't got sorted over into the
other group and so the smoking had
nothing to do with it now this is the
kind of argument that actual lawyers for
the tobacco industry used to make when
they were trying to argue that
scientists had not that smoking causes
cancer and and obviously as a purely
logical fact yes if
if the Sorting didn't work
to make statistically similar subgroups
then that could be an explanation but
then you have to go on and say I don't
care how you sort sort any way you want
right sort based on on Pi sort based on
uh the number of shares of stocks sold
on the shot Stock Exchange sort based on
anything you want no matter how you do
it somehow
the cancer-prone rats are going to go
this way and the non-cancer rats are
going to go that way now that will as it
were as a purely logical matter count as
a as something that would make the
prediction that this group will get more
cancer than that group but we would just
say this is lunacy
because you have no mechanism there's
nothing you know you're just you just
don't like the result okay you don't
like the result and you don't like what
the result is telling you so you're just
grasping at straws that's all that's
going on here
that's what's super somebody who just
says I'm just gonna blankly deny
statistical Independence no matter how
you do this sorting no matter and in
this case you're doing these experiments
Alice is doing an experiment and Bob's
doing an experiment each one is randomly
choosing how to set their device
and it's there where the randomness
comes in how does the device get set and
they could be flipping coins or they
could be running off pie or with doing
whatever the heck they want
and your the bell's only assumption is
that statistically
the group of particles that meet
condition one
will be the same as the group of
particles that meet condition two
where condition one and condition two
are chosen by one of these pseudo-random
kind of processes
now Bell gives a even more extensive
discussion of why this is true but it's
clear that when we say it would
undermine science
experimental method depends upon in all
cases using this yeah I should say one
more thing
there's another idea
which is retro causation
right which is a different idea it's not
just a blank denial of statistical
Independence it says oh statistical
Independence fails because
the nature of the particles when I made
them right
is somehow affected by
at the time I made them okay is somehow
affected by what experimental condition
they would be exposed to in the future
so that's the future
affecting the past that's retro
causation
okay and all of this is to save locality
well that doesn't say vocality so the
first point I want to make is that retro
causation violates Bell's locality
condition
okay and it would be kind of crazy to
think look I I have Bob and Alice and
they're doing their experiments far
apart and I absolutely will not believe
that what Alice does can have a causal
effect on Bob but I believe that stuff
that happens to the Future can have a
causal effect on Bob I mean that's
that's even worse
and it's even worse because if you have
retro causation then because you have
causation from the you certainly have
causation from the past to the future if
you also have causation from the future
to the Past then you're going to be
involved in causal loops and then they
it's very hard to even write down a
coherent Theory I mean wheeler and
Feynman tried to do it it's not clear
they wrote down some equations it's not
clear if they have any solutions
if you if you just have non-locality
you you it doesn't they're they're the
the obvious ways to implement it will
not involve any causal groups you won't
have that problem but the fact is to say
I I want to deny non-locality and
therefore Embrace retro causation well
first of all it retro causation violates
Bell's locality conditions so you
haven't gotten out of it anyway and
you've gotten yourself even to a worse
problem
forgive me because I'm uncertain here
and I'll just fumble over my words and
then you can perhaps co-hear what I'm
saying and say it better than I have
how far does this correlation have to be
so when I hear statistical Independence
opposite of statistical dependence which
I assume is a correlation and it seems
to me clear that even when we sort rats
if we try to do so randomly by picking
the 1 millionth digit of pi and so on
and going forward from there that there
is still some some dependence it's
extremely extremely small now how well
how do we choose the number one million
well okay this person said okay well
let's choose a random number generator
to choose that one million or to choose
some number of the digits of pi okay
well then when we press on the random
number generator why do we choose to
press it five seconds from now versus 10
seconds from now because it would give
you a different number so essentially
what I'm saying is that the world that
we chose the rats from
every single thing here is influencing
our decision
so every single thing is in the so the
rat's temperature is influencing our
decision the the fact that the rats have
a certain amount of hair is influences
our decision and so on so just just
there's a there's an extremely tiny
extremely tiny amount
0.0002 but I don't know is that the fact
that it's non-zero does that have any
implication or does it need to be
non-zero sufficiently large
okay so so let me let me try and address
there are two parts of this I think uh
let me try and address both parts of it
let me just take my simple case so
everybody can follow I have a big group
of rats and some percentage of them say
have a certain Gene I don't even know
about the gene
but you say 60 in the big group have it
and what I want to do is now partition
this into two groups of rats and I want
the two groups to be statistically like
each other and therefore statistically
like the original group which had 60
percent
now if I just flip a coin
it just standard statistics
will tell you all right there'll be
little fluctuates it doesn't mean that
you'll get exactly 60 in each of your
subgroups right one subgroup might end
up with 61 in the other subgroup with 59
those are just statistical fluctuations
um using standard statistical methods
you calculate the likelihood of these
fluctuations if you're worried about
them then you you make a bigger you use
a bigger group okay sure it makes the
fluctuations the probability of the
fluctuation smaller and smaller
um without limit right you can't drive
it to zero but you can drive them below
any epsilonic right right
just to be clear what I'm wondering is
is the presence of any Epsilon does that
undermine the no no because because
the violations of bells and Bell's
inequality says a certain observed
correlation in the lab cannot be greater
than a given number I see I see I mean
actual observed violation of that is so
far
it's not close right it's not like gosh
it's just a tiny bit over and if I just
have a little epsilonic thing somewhere
no no the violation is radically far
away from the limit
so if you say oh maybe the subgroups
aren't exactly the same of course
they're not exactly the same but the
chances of them being sufficiently
different
to account for what's observed and
furthermore of course what's observed is
exactly what's predicted by quantum
mechanics and if if what you were seeing
was just the result of some random
fluctuation then you wouldn't be able to
predict it I mean that's the point about
random fluctuations is you can't predict
them at all but what You observe in the
lab is precisely when you get out of a
quantum mechanical calculation
yeah there's one other thing I just want
to if I can find it quickly from
this thing of bells because it's
relevant to what you said well we could
do this we could do this he says um
actually here's a relevant a relevant
thing to what you just said
um he says
he's talking about you've got some
things you treat as free variables in
this case the choice of whether to do
experiment a or experiment B the choice
of Allison bobnick he says of course
there's an Infinite infamous ambiguity
here
about just what and where the free
elements are
the fields of stern Garlock magnets
could be treated as external that's then
treating those as free variables so I
can just you know I imagine those I set
them when I do the calculation however I
want or fields and magnets could be
included in the quantum mechanical
system with external agents acting only
on external knobs and switches or the
external agents could be located in the
brain of the experimental in the latter
case the setting of the instrument is
not itself a free variable it's only
more or less closely correlated with one
depending on how accurately the
experimenter affects his intention as he
puts out his hand to the knob his hand
May shake and may Shake in a way
influenced by the variables V remember
right now this is now exactly to your
point this is Belle I'm reading right
okay that the disagreement between
locality and quantum mechanics is large
up to a factor of root 2 in certain
sense so some hand trembling can be
tolerated without much change in the
conclusion
quantification of this would require
careful epsilonis okay and I I mean
there's a another
thing that he talks about it which I
just
all right again let me just jump to the
end he's talking about this is the part
that I wanted
consider the extreme case he's now
talking about random generators so we
want something that's setting this
equipment either this way or that way
for Alice something that's setting it
this way or that way for Bob
um it would be a bad idea to have it due
to the as it were whim of the
experimenter because the experimenter
would have to be just sitting there in a
very boring way going oh now up now down
and probably as we know people are not
even good at creating random sequences
right human beings are not good random
number generators right right here's
what he said he says consider the
extreme case of a random generator
which is in fact perfectly deterministic
in nature
and for Simplicity perfectly isolated in
such a device the complete final state
right what what it chooses
perfectly determines the complete
initial State nothing is forgotten
and yet for many purposes such a device
is precisely a forgetting machine
a particular output is the result of
combining so many factors of such
lengthy and complicated dynamical chain
and this is going what you were saying
well what if they do it a little later
or if I've have you know suppose I have
like when they do lotteries they have
these ping pong balls that are bouncing
up and down in this cage okay that could
be a deterministic system so that some
set of causes
account for why this ball came up but
that set of causes is huge it involves
all the other collisions with all the
other balls and all this other stuff
going on so he says
um yet for many purposes such a device
is precisely a forgetting machine a
particular output is the result of
combining so many factors of such
lengthy and complicated dynamical chain
that it is quite extraordinarily
sensitive to minute variations of any
one of many initial conditions it is the
familiar Paradox of classical
statistical mechanics that such
Exquisite sensitivity to initial
conditions is practically equivalent to
complete forgetfulness of them
to illustrate this point suppose that
the choice between two possible outputs
corresponding to a and a prime depending
on the oddness or evenness of the digit
in the millionth decimal place of some
input variable then fixing a or a prime
indeed fixes something about the input
I.E whether the millionth digit is even
or odd but this peculiar piece of
information is unlikely to be the vital
piece for any other distinctively
different purpose I.E it is otherwise
rather useless with a physical shuffling
machine we're unable to perform the
analysis to the point of saying just
what particular feature of the input is
Remembered in the output but we can
quite reasonably assume that it is not
relevant for other purposes in this
sense the device output of such a device
is indeed a sufficiently free variable
for the purposes at hand
for this purpose the Assumption one
which is the statistical Independence
assumption in the proof
is then true enough and the theorem
follows now if you just understand if
you just read that paragraph carefully
and understand it
it puts this whole thing about I'm going
to deny statistical Independence to bed
I mean and this is just Bell okay he
understood this objection he understood
that logically yes he has two premises
so logically you can deny either one but
then he says look denying statistical
Independence that's just not
physically the kind of thing a physicist
could ever do and remain a physicist
here's what's interesting I respect you
I respect Sabine I think you're both
extremely bright people
why is it then that extremely bright
respectable people believe in super
determinism if it's so obviously
incorrect so here's one answer Nima
arkani Hamed said
that there's this mistake that the
public has about physics which is that
almost every moment in time we need some
radically new paradigm that we have to
be revolutionary he said no what is
required is conservative revolutionarism
or revolutionary conservatism whichever
and what he meant by that is
well let's take a look at at Einstein
people say that with special relativity
what he did was extremely revolutionary
they said no he was revolutionary about
one aspect and was extremely
conservative about others he said these
are certain aspects that I want to hold
on to and here's what I'm willing to
give up and then he came up with his
theory do you see it as some people are
extremely conservative about locality
and they're willing to be extremely
revolutionary in other respects like
let's dismiss with statistical
Independence do you see it as that sort
of issue or is it something else I think
it's something else I I look you have to
remember the physicists of course
philosophers everybody are human beings
and and human beings have their oils
um
and
all right let me
I'm gonna illustrate this one of the one
of the physicists who early on
recognized and advertised Bell's result
because you know you have to bear in
mind that
that if if not for some kind of very
lucky things happening Bell's result
might have gone entirely buried and
nobody would have even known about it I
mean it was it was published in the
first volume of a brand new
a journal that went out of business
within a couple years
um so people wouldn't even know about
the journal
it happened to fall in the hands of of
Abner shimoni and shimoni read it and
understood how important it was and
shimoni happened to know John clauser
who was looking for an experimental
project okay there's a there's a whole
history here but it's a it's a very iffy
thing right that Bell's result could
have just completely disappeared
um
but one of the physicists who who early
on
understood the importance of Belle's
result was David merman and Merman was a
good popularizer and he wrote some
articles he also wrote articles that
were published even in philosophy
journals explaining what bell did
um and and the original Bell result the
one that Bell proves
is a statistical result it says if you
there's a certain kind of experiment if
you do it over and over and over and
over again you you then accumulate
statistics about correlations between
outcomes on these two sides and this
Bell inequality
puts mathematical constraints on how
strong those correlations can be and
that's what's violated
and uh merman said he always had a
suspicion
that the probabilistic nature of these
predictions was really essential
right that the fact that you were
dealing not with strict 100 predictions
but only
percentage predictions right was somehow
very deep to this result he said he
could never quite articulate one
and then some years later uh green
Burger horn and zeilinger came up with
this very nice example it's the one I
use all the time now instead of Belle's
original example which instead of
involving pairs of particles involves
triples of particles uh this is in my
book if anybody wants to read it um it's
a beautiful thing to be explained in
five minutes but the nice thing about it
is that the predictions there are not
statistical they're 100 predictions they
say according to Quantum Mechanics you
should get this kind of result
every time
right so if if it even fails once it's
it's Uncle you know quantum mechanics
has failed you know unless they're you
know experimental error but
and
and
when
when merman saw that
he appreciated he wrote a very nice
article about it and he said at the end
I used to think that the probabilities
here were really important I was wrong
okay I there you know this just shows I
was wrong because here you have a
locality result that doesn't involve
probabilities they're all one and zero
and you know you can't ask for more than
that from somebody okay he had his
suspicions he stated them publicly when
he got reasoned to see that that those
were wrong he retracted them publicly
and he wasn't upset about him why would
you be upset about it I mean I often say
the nicest feeling you can have when you
fall asleep at night is that you
understand something you didn't
understand in the morning or you've
corrected an error in your thinking
I mean people don't like to admit errors
to different degrees
um right and that's just human beings
right I mean that's true of all human
beings you have to
try to get familiar enough
with at least some of the content
that you can really make an independent
Judgment of your own about who who's
right and who's wrong and then start
more trusting the people who who are
right and and being more leery about the
people who are wrong there's nothing
else you can do it's unfortunate it's
hard work right
and and and anybody trying to pick up
physics from the kind of uh Public
Presentation is not gonna be in a
position very well to do that as I say
if you're interested in super
determinism get Bell's book read chapter
it's only four pages read chapter 12
read it carefully and think
think for yourself
and and ask yourself whether you think
denying the statistical Independence
assumption that he uses is something
that is it has any physical plausibility
um
that that
and and if you're wondering you know
that that's the best thing to do right
I'm not asked to take it on my word sure
sure so let's talk about the PBR theorem
do you see it as one of the landmark
theorems on par with bell or second or
even perhaps greater than Bells I I
would say I I think it's
it in a certain way as important as
Bell's result
but not as surprising
um that is not a surprising given Bell
that we already know about no no not as
surprising even before Bell
so let me say why I mean the PBR result
says
we use this thing the wave function this
mathematical object at the center of the
mathematical apparatus of quantum
mechanics everybody uses it to calculate
with
and again you know one question you
should ask yourself why is that right
why are we why are we using this thing
one possible answer is well because it's
a pretty good representation of the of
some actual physical reality
in an individual system in an individual
system right it it represents some
physical characteristic of the
individual system in front of me
an irrelevant physical characteristic
right
now
even apart from Bell if you ask well
should I take this wave function
seriously in that sense or should I
rather think it's something merely
epistemic that so the wave function is
kind of for a single particle let's just
talk about a single particle because
it's easier although it's a little
misleading single particle the wave
function is defined over all of space so
you can sort of think of it like a field
and it's spread out and and the
Schrodinger equation tells you how it
evolves and it evolves by a wave
equation good
okay is there anything in any if I send
a single particle through a two-slit
experiment
um I represent that single particle in
part using a wave function and the wave
function is spread out and the wave
equation carries that wave function
through both slips
and from there each slit produces its
own as it were a little wave and then
they interfere like water waves and you
get this interference pattern yeah
and physically what we see if I do this
two-set experiment over and over again
with individual single particles is what
shows up on the screen is this
interference pattern with these
bands through it light and dark bands
now as soon as you see that you say gosh
okay well that wave function must really
represent something physical that does
interact with both slits that's how
interference works right if each
individual particle merely went through
one slit and nothing nothing
interacted with the other sled
then you couldn't possibly get this kind
of interference so the idea that you
should take the wave function seriously
as representing a real physical feature
of individual systems
so nothing to do with anybody's
knowledge nothing to do with
epistemology nothing to do with
statistical characteristics of large
groups of systems
it it represents some physical reality
that pertains to an individual system
that's just from two split interference
everybody should believe that
and everybody I know does believe it
this was not something the people that I
know that work in foundations nobody
ever questioned that because you just
say just the two now two slit
interference does not violate Bell's
inequality so this is not non-locality
this is a different thing
and this is again another place where
you know Feynman makes a mistake when he
says well he wrote this before Belle but
he says all the mysteries of quantum
mechanics are somehow packaged into two
split no they're not
because Bell isn't
but if you just think about those kinds
of familiar interference experiments
okay done with single particles and
where you accumulate the data over time
anybody looking at that is going to say
gosh that wave function must represent a
real physical characteristic of
individual systems now what the PBR
theorem does
is it gives you something even sharper
right it says if you if despite all that
you want to think that there's something
epistemic about the wave function that
it doesn't really represent physical
reality of the individual system it
somehow reflects your information or
something like that then the PBR this is
also called cubism or no well that's
sort of what the cube is said cubism is
I mean cubism is a very difficult
Doctrine to even understand what it's
claiming let's leave it aside for the
moment but someone you know a common
idea was that no the wave function is
kind of spread out not because anything
physical was spread out but because
we're ignorant about where something is
right and the spread outness reflects us
not knowing where it is not that there
is something in these different regions
so uh I think anybody who just thought
about two slit would say no that can't
be right it can't be merely epistemic
and again David merman makes this point
in one article he made the point very
nice with a dialogue a kind of dialogue
with somebody who's trying to be
epistemic and they say oh you know the
wave function spreading out is just a
matter of of our ignorance
and and then in in response somebody
says so it's our ignorance that goes
through the two slits
right interferes right and that makes no
sense right I mean something physical is
interacting with both slits
um it has to be so what what PBR did was
they they took the observation that I
made which is not a proof
and they gave a sharp definition of what
it is to regard the wave function is
representing something real about the
individual system as opposed to
representing something about merely our
knowledge of the system
and then they said well
um
if you believe it's epistemic by our
definition
here's an experiment
that you'll make the wrong predictions
about I mean you'll make predictions
you'll have to make predictions that
violate quantum mechanical predictions
and by the way they also use statistical
Independence assumption in their proof
but that's fine because the statistical
Independence function is fine right you
know I've got a problem with that they
they use one as well
um and it's a nice proof I mean I and
people who reacted at the time who said
this is the most important proof since
Bell I think I think David Wallace said
that I think he's right I think if
you're doing foundations
it just I mean you could say it was the
last nail in the coffin and the coffin
was already shut that you shouldn't have
been an epistemicist in the first place
for you know straightforward physical
reasons right how do you explain these
interference bands
um but if somebody again wanted to be
very recalcitrant and and and stubborn
and say no no no I just really think
there's something epistemic about this
wave function the PBR theorem kind of
puts that to rest and so you can move on
so yeah I think it's very important I
think it's an extremely important thing
I think as I say it's not as astonishing
in what it's claiming as Bell there's a
word a phrase that you use called
foundations of quantum mechanics or
foundations but that's the standard for
foundations of quantum mechanics
infamously when you go to a Physics
course if you get a Physics degree and
you ask about well what does this
so-and-so mean especially when it comes
to Quantum field Theory quantum
mechanics they say hey go to a
philosophy Department essentially what
I'm asking is what textbooks should one
read let's say they're at The Graduate
level in order to become familiar with
Quantum foundations like is there a set
of five books that you feel like hey
read these in this order that gives you
a great introduction well I mean the
thing I I was once did a did a thing at
the end they ask you name five books in
your field that you would recommend
and I said and I was only half joking I
would say I I said okay get this book
and read it five times okay that I mean
I mean you know this is a collection of
Articles and there are different levels
and it's not a single presentation but
Belle is really On Target really really
beautifully out there and you have to be
careful when you read him because he's
he's so precise in the way he writes
that he'll say something once and he
won't beat you over the head with it a
hundred times and you have to pay
attention I beat people over the head
right my technique as I say is to use a
two by four and whack you over the head
a hundred times and say the same thing
um Bells using a scalpel and sort of
just like that like direct yeah I mean
it's just I mean it's beautiful and he's
really again if you're worried about
super determinism just read this four
page paper of bells it's all there
um so you should read that if you're if
you're used to a physics if you're a
physics major and you're used to a
physics presentation there's this nice
book by Travis Morrison that came out I
don't know five years ago
um
I think it's called foundations of
quantum mechanics but it's really
for
physics students
as an introduction to
quantum theory but with attention to the
historical and historical background and
conceptual detail that's not in a normal
physics book
and it goes over interpretations as well
yeah
um then you know David Albert who people
may not know got his degree in
theoretical physics from Rockefeller
University but was interested in
foundations and therefore switched to a
philosophy department so he's in the
philosophy Department of Colombia you
know he wrote a book which is more
philosophical and a little more out
there in certain ways called quantum
mechanics and experience
and it's not you know it it's not like
norson's book which is aimed at physics
students it's it's aimed I mean David's
trying to take as much math out of it
as possible
um and kind of look at the conceptual
issues
um I mean you have my book which is
philosophy of physics quantum theory
which is you know it's more math than
David has and less math than Travis has
all right it's in between the two and
every one of the books you mentioned for
those who are watching that'll be in the
description
um I I I think you know between those
four books
you certainly have everything you need
um
and the book by you what was it called
velocity of physics colon quantum theory
there's a little set of of books it's a
it's a series of books that are supposed
to be introductory books for
philosophers to different issues and I
did the philosophy of physics one but
there are two volumes one is space and
time which is an introduction to
space-time Theory and relativity and the
other is quantum theory which is about
Quantum Theory and Someday I'm gonna do
a third part or put them all together
and do something on statistical
explanation and thermodynamics and
entropy and stuff but that's somewhere
in the future
what the heck is a Bible a Bible be able
yeah so what the heck is a biable and
why did Belle invent this terminology
because to me as an outsider just sounds
like something that exists some
ontological object that's all it is but
that's you see
the word ontology and I can testify from
personal experience it scares physicists
right you say what's the ontology of
their Theory and they go like ontology
okay because they didn't learn Greek
right
um an ontology just means in Greek Anta
are the things that exist and logos is
an account so the ontology of your
theory is tell me what your theory
postulates to exist
and Bell wanted a word for the same
thing now he could have used ontology
but he didn't I don't know why
um I mean he doesn't have a philosophy
background maybe it didn't occur to him
and he even says in a paper he says in
the theory of vocal beibles he said well
he yeah he wanted a word
whose route was to be or to exist as
opposed to observable I mean what he was
doing was setting a contrast with the
term observable
because so many physicists would say oh
physics is about observables observables
observables and Bell said no no
it should be about be a bulls things
that exist
I mean he said he considered be ER b-e
hyphen e r but then that looks like deer
right and then he he he on the model of
observable he put b a bull
um it's you know I would just call it
the ontology of the theory but for
phosphorus would just call it the
ontology of the theory and physicists
should just get used to it's you know
it's but you can call it the Bibles it's
fine because Belle used that
um it's just what what is your physical
Theory
postulate to physically exist now this
is a question which would be the first
question it's not a philosophical
question
it's not oh philosophers are interested
in that no physicists right that's the
founding that's what your physics is
actually postulating to physically exist
right it's the first question you should
ask of any physical theory if you want
to understand it what does it postulate
to actually exist and unfortunately
because foundations of physics does not
is not part of a standard physics
education
which it isn't
um physicists get very nervous around
questions like this and sometimes they
they suggest answers that don't kind of
make any sense so there's a physicist of
why will Who Remain unnamed who was
asked this question at one of our
conferences well what's the you know
what are the Bibles of your theory what
does your theory postulate and came up
with the answer matrices and you want to
say no no that's not even in the right
ballpark right a matrix is a
mathematical object okay I mean a matrix
is a set of numbers in an array you're
not going to tell me the world the
physical world is made up of sets of
numbers in an array well if your max
tegmark well yeah I mean yes yes
take Mark exactly okay I mean you can
talk about and this is a real confusion
it to me I mean it makes when when Max
goes way out and says
the world's just
has a mathematical reality and the the
physical world has no reality that's any
different than any other mathematical
object so every mathematical object is
physically I mean again there's a
certain point at which
quite honestly you just say I don't
really want to spend my time
with this
it's just you know no there's a physical
world right it's true that we can make
really good predictions about it using
some mathematical representations and
that's a good thing to think about and
why those mathematical representations
are so effective that's a really good
thing to do but what you're thinking
about when you think about that is okay
what
might the physical world be like
such that this mathematics
makes such good predictions and that's
why I said that's why I like geometry
because one in in the case of geometry
it at least a possible answer is this
abstract geometry is such a good
representation of the physical world
because the world literally has that
geometrical structure
right then of course it's going to be
pretty good at making predictions
because you've got it right you know
you've got a good representation of the
way it really is and in the case of
geometry I can understand that as a
possibility in the case of you know
pure number Theory I don't understand
what it would be to say look the world
really is is has its numerical structure
I don't know I just don't understand it
um I can't get I can't wrap my head
around what would even mean
uh going back to that geometrical
structure that you were referencing in
the beginning so is that something that
you're currently working on or is there
paper that you can point people to to
learn more about it's something I mean I
I so I wrote a book
called New Foundations for physical
geometry colon the theory of linear
structures
um that came out a while ago and that
was a way of
trying to cover the same content or
conceptual territory that's covered by
standard topology uh points at topology
but in a different way using a different
Foundation
um
and there was always supposed to be a
second volume to that book so the first
volume was just pure math and the second
volume was supposed to be application to
physics and I intended to write that and
I thought it was going to be very
straightforward
and I was writing away at it and then I
was teaching and then I got interested
because one of the things that happens
in the first book Is I develop a way of
thinking about topology which applies
both for continua and for discrete
spaces because the standard
Point set topology doesn't really work
well in a discrete setting it just gives
you kind of trivial answers
um anyway I got interested in this idea
of discrete geometry and then I started
developing this thing I call full
discrete geometry and so this will
eventually come out as the second volume
of New Foundations of physical geometry
uh I can't say exactly when I mean I've
got six chapters that are all about
spatial structure and a few chapters now
about adding time in for space time and
I I have some really exciting recent
results which I was talking about which
are not published but but if you're
interested I've given the talk
a lot of times in fact I just gave the
talk for the International Space Science
Institute and they've put it up on the
web
um within the last couple
um so yeah that that I mean I've got
more work to do
to finish that book I kind of see how
it's going to go there's some
calculations and things
um and some some examples that I need to
think through
um
eventually that will come out
there was a phrase that I heard you say
with Einstein the general view is that
he spatialized time but instead what we
should do is temporalize space right
okay so please expand on that because
that sounds poetic I don't know what it
means
okay so right so
one thing that people say that is just
flat incorrect is that in in special
relativity somehow
time is just another spatial Dimension
or that they're placed on equal footing
they're yeah placed on quote as you say
equal footing that's just a phrase also
that that you never hear anywhere else
except in special relativity so then
that makes me think that people are just
copying that phrase because you never
use the word equal footing in math or
physics except here when talking about
space and time everyone repeats it like
the PowerHouse of the cell is
mitochondria good good good you you've
put your finger on something which is
really smart
and really perceptive and you should use
it all the time when a when a whole
bunch of different people are using
identically the same language
it's an indication of a problem
because if you really understand
something
when you speak about it you'll you won't
always use the same phrases and
different people will use slightly
different phrases or you know produce
different analogies and so on because
they understand it
and then they're filtering their
understanding through language to try
and convey that understanding when
everybody's repeating verbatim the same
phrase they've just memorized that
phrase right it's an indication of lack
of really understand I mean look think
about it I agree wholeheartedly about
you know think think about the term
equal footing if by equal footing you
mean equal then why don't they say as
they say why don't they say oh he made
everything into time
but they say no somehow he made
everything into space right now we know
what it would be we know what it is
to add an extra spatial Dimension so we
start out thinking space has three
dimensions you think it might have four
five we know the tool to represent that
it's four-dimensional Romanian geometry
well-defined mathematical subject that's
not relative
right the the the the geometry of
special and general relativity is not
rimani in Geometry it's lorencian and
because it's lorencian it contains a
light cone structure that pseudo purely
spatial structure has nothing that
corresponds to a like
Okay so
to say they're on equal footing I mean
again it's kind of also a little vague
what that means but it certainly doesn't
mean that you've just turned time into
space and the real problem of people
saying that you've turned time into
space is that space doesn't have a
directionality
that is if I were to just go to somebody
in the street and say you know
the United States runs from north to
south and not south to North they'd look
at me like what in the world are you
even saying
right what do you mean
um there's a north-south dimension if
you will but it doesn't go one way
rather than another okay whereas if I
tell you time goes from past to Future
and not from the future to the Past
everybody says yeah of course I mean
that's a triviality everybody know time
has a Direction
everybody we're constantly getting older
right every you wake up there's some
that we'll get to that say time is an
illusion so I'll get your your thoughts
okay but anyway time intuitively time
has a direction and space doesn't
and if if by equal footing
people took the lesson which many of
them do is they say oh first of all by
equal footing you mean you've
spatialized time somehow time has now
just become more space but space doesn't
have a Direction so gee I guess time
doesn't have a direction now you're in a
complete mess
um now when I say you're temporalizing
space what I mean is something very when
I said that is something very precise
take a relativistic space time
and blind yourself
to everything except just the temporal
structure the proper time structure
okay
from that you can recover the whole
thing okay sorry repeat that one more
time from the time structure from the
proper time structure
you can recover the entire structure
right information about the the whole
space-time geometry is contained within
if you just give me all the causal
curves all the time like or light-like
Curves and their proper lengths in right
in proper time
that nails down the entire space on
Geometry
So to that extent you could say time
settles everything time has a direction
we're going to save that yep
but we agree space doesn't appear to
have a preferred direction right
because it doesn't somehow we can
generate space from a preferred time
Direction
you can generate the spatial structure
yeah
yeah
there's only one special structure
that's consistent there's only one
relativistic full relativistic metric
that's going to be consistent with just
the temporal part
now is this written somewhere in the
paper or is this an idea that you're
twenty look here's what's here here's
some stuff that's well known it's not
original to me
just forget about just give me the light
cone structure so we all know I hope
that in a relativistic setting space
time has a light cone structure so any
event there's a double cone of right
cone and a past light
and let me just comment on that it's
important that it's a double cone that
is if I have an arrow pointing into the
upper part of this of this light
I can't continuously rotate it down into
the bottom so it's pointing the other
direction and always have it Point
timeline that is have a point within the
cone the the time like directions are
divided into two disconnected groups the
future pointing ones in the past
pointing ones but the space-like
directions which are the directions that
as it were Point outside the light cone
they're continuously connected I can get
from any space like direction to any
other one just always remaining
spaceline right so that's the sense in
which time has a direction there's a
fundamental distinction between the
future directed
things and the past directed things and
there's no corresponding distinction in
space
now what's well known is if I just give
you the light cone structure just the
light cone structure to specify a
relativistic metric I need 10 numbers
if I give you just the light cone
structure that nails down nine of them
okay
that's well known this was proven a long
time ago so there's just one other
number that I need and if you give me
not just the light cone structure but
the the length the so these time-like
curves have a length that's called a
proper time if you tell me that that'll
nail down the tens number interesting
done okay there's no other there's no
other wiggle room you've got everything
this is well known this is not anything
special to me
and so just to be clear when we were
talking about that if you're in the
upper part of a light cone then you
can't go to the bottom part we're in a
orientable manifold or does this still
apply and it's always the Assumption
when you do relativity always always the
assumption that the manifold is
temporally orientable so it's not like a
Mobius strip where you know things get
twisted up and that's because I missed
two directions
I would like to know your thoughts on
Occam's razor whether it's a good
principle what are its pros and cons and
this relates to the manifolds but we'll
get to that so what are your thoughts
your what are the pros and cons of
Occam's razor well again the part of the
problem is when people use the term
Occam's razor they often have different
principles in mind
um
so what Occam said was something like
Anthea nonsense
uh whatever it is it's in a Prater in
the quesatum don't postulate entities
without necessity
now the problem with that is that what
do you mean by necessity
um if if you take that too strongly then
it's kind of a crazy view because you're
never really necessitated to postulate
things so so then you weaken it you say
look don't postulate entities without
good reason that that sounds good but
that's kind of trivial I mean you should
also not delete entities without good
reason okay you shouldn't do anything
without good or you just use good
reasons okay it becomes good advice but
kind of trivial
um yeah sometimes people say well
Occam's razor says if I have two rival
theories
and one postulates fewer things than the
other so again we go to the idea of
ontology or beables
then you should prefer the one with
fewer
right some many times people say oh
that's Occam's race take the one with
fewer that's certainly not advice that
physicists follow and I think for good
reason why for example take a classical
electromagnetic Theory
of the sort that that Max welded
so it's got charged particles that's
part of the ontology
and it's got Fields it's got
electromagnetic fields
now you can imagine a theory that gets
rid of the fields and a kind of action
at a distance Theory this is what we'll
learn fine when we're doing you just
throw away the fields and you say no no
it's not that discharged particle
affects that one by the effect of an
intermediate field it's that this one is
directly affects that one maybe with a
time lag with nothing between them well
clearly that second theory has less
ontology than the first one because it's
you know they both have the particles
and one has the fields in the other
doesn't doesn't mean it's a better
theory in fact it it seems like a much
worse Theory because you give up certain
principles of continuous action and so
on in in favor of this you know spooky
action at a distance or whatever
um I mean no physicists took that very
would take that seriously they'd say
look wait I but I have a whole set of
equations for the electric and magnetic
fields I understand how they behave I
understand how jiggling this charged
particle creates an electromagnetic
field that goes through space and time
and then hits this charge particle in an
antenna and makes it go up and down and
then I turn on my radio okay and if
somebody wants to explain that taking
away the intermediary Fields that's just
a very strange thing to do I certainly
shouldn't think
that you know less is more
in ontology
so
again if it's just if the advice is look
just think about the ontology when
you're comparing two theories
compare their ontology and ask what is
the justification
where one has more
if one strictly has more what's the
justification think about that
justification that's good advice but
it's not good advice to say no don't
even think about that just just compare
them and then and and announce that the
one with less ontology is better
because you don't you have to think
about what price you're paying yeah get
rid of it with the Feynman case with
wheeler was their mathematical treatment
more complex than the original
electromagnetic from oh yeah because
because the the wheeler Feynman Theory
tried to get rid of the electromagnetic
fields in favor of and now this comes
back to the stuff about retro causation
in favor of having direct action at a
distance both to the past and to the
Future so what what the way a particle
charged particle behaves right now
was determined by looking both on its
past light cone and seeing where there
are other charged particles on the past
light cone and what they're doing and on
the future right cone and where there
are other particles on the future of
Icon and what they're doing
and so you had instead of what we
normally have which is a boundary
condition a single boundary condition
from which you generate the future in
the past you had a boundary condition to
the past and a boundary condition to the
Future and to the Future they use this
thing called an absorber a perfect
absorber condition blah blah blah but
just mathematically that's a much more
difficult problem
much more difficult problem to know you
can write down some equations to know
whether they even have any solutions
it's just mathematically all very
intractable
okay so then it's intractable which
means that they weren't able to produce
or reproduce the results yeah as far as
I know I mean I know knew some people
who were interested in this Theory
uh in Munich and you know recent I mean
within the last 20 years and we're
working on it and to my knowledge they
never exactly got a precise solution
either but I haven't looked at it in
much detail it's coming it's just clear
on mathematical grounds
when you have something like Newton's
equations
if you give me an initial condition and
tell me the positions and moment of all
the particles
then there then you can prove in certain
circumstances there's a unique solution
to the Future there's a unique solution
to the past and you can actually get
your hands on it right mathematically
but when you say no now I have a
situation where I have one boundary
condition to the past and one boundary
condition to the future and I'm trying
to solve in between
it just mathematically I mean you can
imagine how do you go about it I mean in
the case of Newton literally you imagine
on a computer you set some data here and
then the computer computes okay then a
little later this then a little later
this then it just builds it up or a
little earlier this a little early
builds it down but if I if I give you
data here and here and I have to somehow
fill in the middle in a way that's
consistent with it it's not even quite
clear how you proceed if wheeler and
Feynman were able to reproduce it you
would still have the same objection it's
complex I I'm not sure I mean you would
really have to ask yourself look if the
theory that postulates electromagnetic
fields
has this simple Newtonian presentation
which it does
right I just do an initial Simplicity
needs to factor in two so sorry I don't
mean to interrupt I apologize so
Simplicity has to factor in as well it's
not just less assumptions is there
another quality like Aesthetics is there
like what are the factors that need to
be in place because Occam's it's the way
it's ordinarily state is you have
competing theories which everyone has
less assumptions but produces the same
results you choose that one yeah I mean
I I again
even the if you're a magician if you're
like a philosopher and you're used to
these logical tricks you say well what
do you mean fewer assumptions if if I
have a theory with 10 assumptions then I
just put a conjunction between them and
I have a single sentence that's where I
was getting at well that's my objection
with Occam's razor it's all it's to me
it's unclear what counts as an
assumption so some people say the
simplest is God did it but I don't know
if God is one assumption or if it's ten
I just pause it space time is that one
assumption space-time has a huge
structure so it's like a manifold is
like second countable hawsdorf and then
there's atlases and then there's
orientations so is that one assumption
yeah and I I think quite honestly it's a
Fool's errand to think that you can come
up with some abstract statement of a
methodological principle that'll be the
right one to apply in all cases I mean
start with the problem in front of you
the problem in front of you is going to
be here's one Theory here's another
theory
and let's assume that they make the same
empirical predictions or where they
differ you can't check or something so
you can't say I'm just going to do an
experiment to try and decide between
them
then people will will start producing
justifications for taking thinking one
is more plausible than the other
and your job is to think through those
justifications now I I don't think any
you know single sentence in Latin is
going to give you very helpful advice
Universal advice about how to do that
um it might be that in some sense one of
the theories is simpler is is clearly
simpler than the other with no penalty
then you'd say okay the simpler one just
seems more plausible but usually there
are trade-offs
how important are they how much of this
will you give up for that there's no
going to be not going to be a general
calculus of this you should just try to
be as explicit as you can in the
accounting
right so you say here's Theory one
here's its ontology here its laws here's
Theory two here's its ontology here's
its laws
um
if I prefer if if on grounds other than
empirical grounds I prefer a to B let me
say why and then just listen right I
mean you know and the kind of the kind
of justification you might get may be
very specific to the particular
mathematics being used I mean God knows
what I mean don't don't expect some guy
you know in the Middle Ages wrote down
something that is going to give you the
Royal Key to deciding between these
things and maybe there's no good way to
decide between them I mean we should be
prepared
to have alternative physical accounts of
the world that we don't actually have
any particularly good reason to decide
between and if that's the situation
that's the situation
you know
speaking of what's what's tricky to
decide between the illusion of time so
there are certain theories in well
there's certain interpretations of time
such as Carlo rivelli's there's Julian
Barbers we'll get to them what does the
PBR theorem have to say about relational
quantum mechanics
yeah so so yeah you you did give me some
warning you were going to ask that
question and and I I afraid I just have
to say I don't understand relational
quantum mechanics I've looked at it a
bit I talked to Carl about it a bit I
just don't understand it
uh I know some people who've looked at
it more carefully and they were unable
to find what they considered a coherent
formulation of it
um if you feel like you understand it
then you can explain it to me and I can
try to respond if you feel like you
don't really understand it and can just
repeat what other people say we're a bit
stuck
uh I just I just don't understand what
the theory claims even apart from time
and then my issue here isn't about time
um I I don't understand what it means to
say that all that's real are relations
it's I mean sometimes there's this tag
phrase that people say oh relations
without rolata
and this is you know you're just
contradicting how can you have a
relation without Roboto or
um things only exist when they interact
and then you want to say but wait if
they weren't already there how could
they interact I mean how can how can
interaction occur between two things
that don't exist
um I I don't I literally don't
understand what's being claimed
um I once I mean I can uh if and again
if you feel like you want to explain it
to me I'm I'm all ears I I will again
one one little data point was was once I
was puzzled about stuff talking to Carl
and we were talking about non-locality
right so in the non-locality case Alice
does an experiment over here and Bob
does an experiment very far away and the
issue is the correlations between the
outcomes of the experiments they do
right that that's what Bell's inequality
puts constraints on on these
correlations
and uh
as far as I could understood Carlos
seemed to be saying that that
uh there is no outcome for Bob
just you can't just talk about what
happened in Bob's lab right you normally
think you could you say okay Bob did an
experiment did he get a DOT here or a
DOT there you know was it an up or down
outcome and it's like no no no he only
had an outcome relative to Alice and
furthermore somehow that outcome only
occurs when Alice and Bob interact and
Allison Bob only interact when after the
experiment they come back together and
share data or something like that
and and I said don't understand Carlos
so if I'm Bob
and I do my experiment right and I have
my data and then I'm waiting for Alice
Alice's to come meet me to share her
data and Alice comes and she says you
know uh 10 minutes ago I just got this
result
do I not believe her
I mean do I literally just not believe
yes you got that result 15 minutes ago
long before I ever found out about it
and long before we ever interacted
and and Carl just looked at me like I'd
asked a question that never occurred to
him I mean he didn't have a ready answer
at the time I don't know if he does now
and at that point I just don't
understand I mean I think Alice is there
doing her experiments and getting her
outcomes and Bob is there doing his
experiments and getting his outcomes
quite even though they're not
interacting with each other
in a normal sense of interaction
um
and those outcomes are what they are and
they do or they do not violate Bell's
inequality
I don't understand what the relational
Theory says about that case I have some
puzzlement because I asked Carlo well
what's being related and then I believe
he said certain relations then I said
well what are those relating and is it
not just some infinite regress of
relations and then he said yes
all right
but look this is I mean saying yes is
very is is maybe it's honest it's kind
of fun I mean there's a Dr Seuss story
about the about about the lazy bees in
Hotshot right so um so you know they
they find that when the bee Watcher
watches the bees they're they're busier
so they hire a b Watcher but the B
Watcher was lazy so they had to hire a b
Watcher Watcher and then if you watch or
watch her to watch The Bee Watcher and
and
um you know it's the same thing people
say well you know reality doesn't exist
until an observer observes something and
you say but wait did The Observer
already exist
oh no no The Observer only exists
because some super Observer was
observing The Observer but did the super
Observer already exist oh no there had
to be a super super Observer and then
you said this is just silly I mean you
know why are you doing this and if
someone said well is it Turtles all the
way down yes they're an infinite there's
an infinite hierarchy of observers
observing other observers bringing them
into existence you just say look you can
say this stuff
but why are you doing it I mean we've
perfectly good accounts of the physics
here that don't involve this kind of
ridiculous gymnastics
what's motivating you to say things like
that yeah so the way that I view it and
again just so we're clear Carlo another
a huge admiration for Carlo huge
intellectual giant so I'm Switzerland
when it comes to this I think that many
people they believe that and I'm not
categorizing Carlos this I'm referring
to those people about The Observers and
infinite regress of super observersal
not regress but superset yeah I think
that people
including myself including everyone I
think that people reason backward and we
believe that we're reasoning from found
it we say first principles almost no one
is a first principles thinker we have
certain values that we're trying to
preserve and we reason backward and we
say well you know how a implies B is the
exact same as not B implies not a let me
give you a story
I was driving with someone who is of
extremely liberal temperament and I'm
not there's nothing wrong with that and
I said oh that dog breed is known for
being extremely intelligent then she's
like no
I'm like what do you mean no it's just
known for being Intel it has a higher IQ
she's like what what are you talking
about higher IQ in in dogs and then I
realized what's happening is that she
believed that what could be done is I
could then infer onto humans and say oh
well there are different species here so
because that is not she wants to
preserve that she reasons backward okay
so I believe that that's what's
occurring in many of these cases well I
look there there's a there's a tradition
there's a tradition going back to bore
and it's kind of associated with the
Copenhagen school or the Copenhagen
Spirit or whatever
um
that thinks that the the great
revolution in quantum theory is because
the Observer unlike In classical physics
unlike in Newtonian physics
The Observer somehow plays a central
role
in quantum theory
and uh the problem is that on no actual
existing precise understanding of
quantum theory that we have is that true
it's just there I mean for many years
for decades there's been a intermittent
series of meetings and the title of the
meetings is quantum theory without the
Observer and it's just
formulations uh theories that would
would account for the quantum phenomena
uh where in their formulation they never
mentioned observers and and there's a
wonderful phrase that Bell has at one
point he says this is a theory that is
neither requires nor is embarrassed by
the existence that are Observer right I
mean it's not that the physics is going
to have trouble modeling observers their
physical systems but gee you know I I
mean we all think don't we that shortly
after the big bang a whole bunch of
physical stuff happened and there was
nobody there observing it
I mean it's kind of again you you kind
of blows your mind when you try and see
what are you even thinking if you think
that that physics needs observers to go
on it's just the opposite observers are
physical systems of a certain kind and
you want the physics
to describe how they behave
as by pure analysis of them as physical
systems and it's the same thing for
measurement right a measurement whatever
you call a measurement is just a
physical interaction between two things
that's going to be described by some
physical equations that don't mention
the word measurement and that's again go
read Bells against measurement against
quote measurement he says the term
measurement should not appear in the
formulation of any theory that pretends
to be foundational
because measurement isn't the right kind
of concept
to appear in the foundations of physics
measurement is a derivative concept
um
Observer is a derivative concept
they shouldn't appear in the foundations
of physics but lots of people convince
themselves that you know again here is
where I think there's something
semi-mystical
so there are people who like the idea
that that observers should become
Central to the universe
they liked it
it just it annoys them that observers
seem to be this tiny tiny little
specials class of uh of of of of you
know humans in particular some tiny
little you know specs on something not
playing a very Central role in physics
and they have an emotional attachment of
something of some sort but but it seems
to me contrary to physics as we
understand it and certainly nobody's
ever made progress doing that nobody's
ever made progress saying oh here I'm
going to write the Observer into the
foundations of physics
and people have made progress doing the
opposite
okay so two notes Here number one there
exists perfectly coherent formulations
theories of quantum mechanics that don't
involve observers sure okay so that's
interesting by the way Theory the grw
collapse Theory I mean the many worlds
theory in so far as you can make sense
of it certainly does not make any
reference to observers
I mean these are theories where they're
they're written in the equations I mean
again Bell says somewhere I want a
theory where the physics is in the
equations and not in the surrounding
talk right
um the these are all theories where you
postulate a Quantum State maybe you
postulate some local bubbles in addition
to that and you write down some clean
equations about how they behave and
that's the theory that doesn't mention
observers it doesn't mention
measurements it doesn't mention anything
like that there's some physical stuff
that you postulate it behaves in a
certain way that you postulate and then
you see what happens so pilot wave many
worlds and then what what were the other
the collapse Theory
romini Weber objective collapse theories
there I mean there are class of
objective object so-called objective
reduction theories I mean Penrose has a
kind of sketch of a theory for many
years he's had a sketch of a theory
which ties the collapses to gravity the
grw theory doesn't you know what do you
make of penrose's theory
I mean I I understand he he takes the
foundational questions seriously
and foundationally
you only have three options okay that's
why you can kind of have a nice
taxonomy of
solutions to the measurement problem
you can say that
you you what you do is just logically
you get into trouble if you try to
maintain three principles principle one
that the wave function
that's used in all these quantum
theories provides a complete description
of a physical system and this was the
epr paper in 1935 the Einstein Podolski
Rosen paper the title of it is the
quantum mechanical description of
reality complete meaning if I give you
the wave function can you somehow derive
from it all the physical facts about the
system they were arguing you can't they
were arguing it's incomplete okay
many war and Heisenberg wanted to say it
was complete so you have one principle
is the wave function complete
the second question does it always
evolve by Schrodinger's equation
Schrodinger's equation is linear that's
a very important feature of it
third claim is that when you do a
Schrodinger cat experiment the cat the
single cat you start with one cat you
end with one cat and the single cat is
either alive or dead Okay that was
Schrodinger's point he thought that's
obvious
you can't maintain all three right you
just as a matter of logic you can't
maintain the wave function is complete
that it always involves by Schrodinger's
equation and that the cat ends up alive
or dead
what does it complete mean once more
what does complete mean it complete
means if I give you the wave function of
a system you can derive from that
somehow all the physical facts about it
all of its physical characteristics does
that mean that it has that you could
find out whether it's spin up and then
spin it means you could find out
anything that's a physical fact about it
I'm not telling you what the physical
facts are but any physical fact
is determined by the wave function
so are there theories that say no you
can't sure that pilot wave theory ah
Deborah I mean the de Broly boom or
bromine mechanics okay in in bohomian
mechanics
the ontology the Bibles there too
there's the universal wave function of
the universal Quantum State that's one
and then there are these particles and
the particles are just classical Point
particles they have always have definite
positions they move around
okay
but if I just give you the quantum State
you that doesn't tell you where the
particles are the where the particles
are the actual configuration of
particles is not derivable from that
it's an additional piece of physical
data
and the way that theory works is you say
okay how does the wave function evolve
answer Always by Schrodinger's equation
okay how do the particles move how does
this particle configuration change
that's given by a second equation called
the guidance equation and the guidance
equation has as an input to it the wave
function
so that's a theory where you say the
wave function is not complete there are
there are additional physical facts
really oh sorry I understand what you're
saying now yes all right I got it yeah I
could have two systems that have exactly
the same Quantum state but are different
physically because the particles are in
different locations
right so you can't maintain that the
wave function is complete and it always
evolves by Schrodinger's equation and
that the cat ends up either just playing
alive or plain dead okay got to give up
one of those three if you give up the
completeness of the wave function then
you have what's called a hidden
variables Theory like bohmian mechanics
pilot wave
if you give up the Schrodinger Evolution
then you have an objective collapse
Theory you say okay the wave function
doesn't always evolve by Schroeder's
equation
and if you don't give up those two then
you're stuck with many worlds and you
say well the cat doesn't end up either
alive or dead somehow one cat becomes
two cats or many cats some of which are
alive and some of which are dead okay
those are your only three options just
as a matter of logic
I mean I have a paper about this called
three measurement problems which goes
through in more detail this is a nice
thing because if somebody says here's my
understanding of quantum mechanics you
can immediately ask them these
diagnostic questions okay according to
the quantum State complete according to
you does it always evolve by
Schrodinger's equation according to you
does a single Cat end up either just
alive or just dead and if they say
oh I I you know I want to maintain
the kind of intuitive answer to all
three say I'm sorry you can't right then
then it's not a coherent Theory
um and once they answer which one
they're going to give up of those three
then you sort of understand where you
are and you understand how the
questioning goes on from there
um
so yeah this is extremely extremely
important yeah
so I mean look Penrose Penrose has gone
for an objective reduction theory and
that this follows if you go and read Von
Neumann's book mathematical foundations
of quantum mechanics Von Neumann and
this was taken as kind of the Bible of
a clean mathematical formulation of
Copenhagen
Von Neumann is very clear he says States
physical systems can undergo two
completely different sorts of evolution
process a and process B of process one
and process two I can't remember what he
uses one of them is Schrodinger
Evolution and the other is a collapse
right right right and they're very
different and if if you think that then
you have an object objective reduction
theory now that's the way Penrose wanted
to go for a long time
and then the question if you have a
reduction theory you say okay well when
does this collapse occur what triggers
the collapse
or does anything trigger the collapse
right what governs the collapse if you
will
um you better not say Well it collapses
when you make a measurement because then
you what when do you make a measurement
there's a measurement now you're back to
against measurement
Penrose wanted to tie the collapses to
gravity somehow
and he had a sort of
slightly hand wavy account of that which
actually a similar account was given by
a guy named karolihazi long ago he was
also when corollary housing was great I
heard him once when I was very young and
he would say well as it were you have
these two gravitational situations which
by Schrodinger evolution
it's like you know the they're they're
they're they're separating and the gra
there's a gravitational difference
between them and then it's at some point
that gravitational gets so big and this
is what corollary houses said he said
then Gabriel comes and blows his trumpet
and the blowing of the trumpet was the
signal the wave function shall now
collapse and it'll either go this way or
that way right
and so you know penrose's idea was to
tie somehow these collapses to to
gravity uh the gerardi Remini Weber
Theory doesn't do that it doesn't tie
them to anything it just gives you a
fixed probability per unit time per
particle that they'll be a collapse so
these are objective reduction theories
it's a way to go
they the objective reduction theories
make in principles slightly different
predictions empirical predictions uh
than the other theories so you can kind
of test in the lab and the grw kind of
theory
I mean people keep doing tests and
ruling out certain parameters space and
there's not much parameter space left
for it
um in another 10 years it may be
empirically empirically refuted to
reiterate its completeness so is there
more information necessary to specify
what's physically going on and in the
case just to be clear again balmian
mechanics and pilot wave are synonyms
yeah okay and then so in Pilot wave
theory it says there's a wave and a
pilot
no the wave is the pilot okay sorry the
wave the quantum State call it the
quantum State that's the thing that's
described mathematically by the wave
function
okay
it's job physically is to Pilot or guide
the particles okay to determine how the
particles move
and it does so via a a precise equation
called the guidance equation
I mean bell bell presented it that way
but boom when he did it I mean the
original idea was de broily and then de
broily dropped it for bad reasons and
then bone rediscovered it but bone
presented the theory as a kind of
Newtonian Theory with something he
called the quantum potential that turns
out to be a bad idea Bell presented it
in terms of the guidance equation which
is the right way to do it
um so the piloting is done by the way as
it were by the quantum State and what
pilots or what it guides are the part of
it a surfer on the wave is the particle
something like that you can think of it
that way now the the thing that you have
to wrap your head around
that's hard for this theory is if you
have a single particle you can really
think of it that way you've got kind of
a wave in physical space and it's
telling the particle where to go but as
soon as you get two particles or three
particles or four interact
whether they interact or not the weight
function is now defined not on physical
space but on configuration space which
is of Three N Dimension so for four
particles it's a 12 dimensional space
and this is just standard quantum
mechanics this is not peculiar to this
Theory
and essentially what that high
dimensional object is doing is governing
the entire configuration of particles it
it doesn't it's not as if as it were one
part of the wave is telling this
particle where to go and another part of
the wave is telling this particle while
ago is that the whole wave is telling
the entire collection of particles
how to evolve that's why it's a kind of
non-local theory that's why that's how
the non-locality gets into it it's a
kind of global holistic Theory where
everything is being done together at the
same time
if you will
are there separate pilot waves for each
of the particles or is there one pilot
wave no no there is one I mean in this
theory if you take it seriously
ultimately there is one Quantum State
and that one Quantum state is the
Quantum state of the entire universe
and what it determines is how the entire
configuration of everything in the
universe behaves
and then there's a very interesting
question which to which there's very
there are very interesting and precise
answers
well if that's true that's not what we
ever use in our calculations right when
I go into the lab
I don't use the universal wave function
of everything I assign a little size so
in the in the literature those big PSI
which is the fundamental thing it's the
wave function of everything the entire
universe and then there's little PSI
which is something I would assign to a
subsystem and then there's a question of
well how do what's the status of this
little side that I actually use and
there's a very nice answer to that it's
called the conditional wave function the
answer is mathematically clear this is
all covered in my book as well uh and
the conditional wave function
sometimes evolves by Schrodinger's
equation and sometimes does something
that looks like a collapse
interesting and all of that is just a
consequence of these two equations that
are at Universal scale
so there's a really beautiful
explanation in this theory of why people
use collapses to do calculations and to
the the extent to which that's Justified
even though in this Theory there are no
collapses on the single fundamental
Quantum state which is the Quantum state
of the entire universe there's a
wonderful answer to that and it's an
answer that's not available in other
theories I mean there's a nice story to
be told and you use this word theories
which is interesting because when one
takes quantum mechanics and University
they're taught or they're told you're
going to learn quantum theory and you
would say at least from my observation
from your talks well a theory needs to
have an account of what is so he needs
to have some ontology or some way that
the mathematics relates to what is you
can't just speak about the mathematics
so that's why
you are not calling I've been listening
to you you're not calling these
interpretations of quantum mechanics you
kept saying these are different theories
because you don't see quantum theory as
having multiple interpretations you see
each of them as separate quantum
theories that's right well my view is
very I mean I say it over and over again
I don't really know how anyone would
dispute it what you're taught when you
take a course is not a theory why
because a theory postulates
the existence of certain things it tells
you look here's what here I am a theory
about the physical world here's what I'm
saying is in the physical world and
here's how it behaves that's what a
physical theory is what you're taught is
a scheme for making predictions
okay it's a predictive recipe
it says oh in this circumstance use this
mathematical object and solve it in this
way and then you pull pull out of thin
airborne's rule to make probabilistic
predictions okay it's a
prediction-making apparatus
but it doesn't even attempt to be a
theory it doesn't pretend to be a theory
because if it were a theory you could
say okay how do I understand this wave
function that you're using does that
represent anything physically real and
it would give you an answer the answer
might be yes the answer might be no but
it would be an answer and what you're
taught doesn't give you an answer
that's why people use this phrase shut
up and calculate
they'd say look I've given you this wave
function I've told you how to manipulate
it to make your predictions now shut up
and calculate don't ask me whether it
represents anything physically real and
so it's not a theory and then what
people call interpretations of quantum
theory are really explicit physical
theories that make precise postulates
about what exists and how it behaves
that are designed
to give you within Epsilon sometimes not
exactly but pretty nearly the
predictions that come out of this
predictive recipe what's wrong with the
shut up and calculate mindset
so why can't we simply have both hey
there are some people who are going to
investigate Subterranean find the Sharks
and the giant squid and then there are
those on the top they're like hey I'm
gonna build the cities and make
technology and sure you can say it's
also exists what difference does it make
for me at some points you provide
insights and they come up to the surface
and maybe we inform you you do you will
do us is there something wrong with that
no
division of labor I mean it's the the
same division of labor one has typically
between engineering and fundamental
physics so let me just give you an
analogy suppose I'm an engineer I'm
interested in building bridges
and I'm just fooling around at some
point with different metal alloys
and I make an alloy that has some really
nice properties for bridge building
right it's light and it's very sturdy
and so on and I say ah good
I'm going to use this to make my bridges
I can now make lighter Bridges and
stronger Bridges good as an engineer I'm
happy
then somebody comes along and says but
why that alloy I mean why is that alloy
so much
stronger than other Alloys now as an
engineer I don't have a complaint about
the engineer saying I don't care
I don't care why it works I don't need
to understand why it works for my job I
just have to know that it works
I have to know that it is in fact light
and strong which I can test and look it
is if you if you physicists want to try
and figure out why this much bismuth and
this much tin and this much you know
Iron happens to form a structure that's
so light fine go to it I as an engineer
could not care less
my job is done when I built the bridge
and I'm sure it's going to work so
that's a division of labor
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna rag on the
engineer you can say well at least they
ended up building a bridge you know they
made life better people can now travel
across the river I'm not making a value
judgment I I am saying from my personal
point of view
I want to know why it works
it's not to me I'm just a nosy person
okay I'm not focused on on uh practical
outcomes I'm just not I'm not saying a
curious person I'm just curious I would
be interested to know why that
particular mix of metals
is so much better than other mixes of
metals and that's the kind of thing that
the physicists would get into and try to
describe in fine detail what's this
underlying structure
now you know some physicists have
decided from my point of view when it
comes to Quantum Mechanics they're happy
to be engineers
right they say okay you've given me this
wave function and you've told me how to
calculate with it and that's enough for
me to design my chips or you know blah
blah blah I'm happy I'm but personally
I'm not happy I don't really care about
the chips I want to understand what's
really going on right I understand what
the world is really made of so I want to
go deeper than that but that's that's
you know I can't say that that's
intrinsically better thing to do
certainly you would not have made all
the material progress that has been made
using quantum mechanics
um if people got stuck because they
didn't understand it right so shut up
and calculate was efficient
but it's really bad if people think
there's something wrong with the small
minority of us who are not satisfied
with it right there's something there's
something illegitimate about people who
say but I really want to know what's
going on not for any practical purpose
and of course most of physics is like
that I mean when they built the the
Large Hadron Collider to try and see if
the Higgs particle existed
it wasn't because you would make better
computers or build bigger Bridges or
have some practical consequence that
came out of what the exact mass of the
Higgs is
nobody could foresee they would have any
interesting practical consequences
you're just curious right what's going
on foreign
to me that's the fundamental impulse of
of being interested in physics it's just
you know falmos it's Wonder at the
universe it's trying to understand
things
now some people
aren't driven by that and they're more
interested in building things or they're
more interested and I I don't want to
say they're you know what they're doing
is bad
but you know we've at least a few of us
who are motivated by pure intellectual
curiosity to go about our business
yes and I find that there's a bit of
condescension from the hardcore
physicist toward the philosophers I
don't know if it's an understatement
yeah I wish that wasn't there it's
getting better though it really is
getting better I mean if you didn't
notice it was just within the last week
I think I saw it on Facebook an
editorial published in
nature physics
okay we don't know who wrote it it's
just an editorial from the editorial
board not signed
which is basically saying you know
there's really a reason to look at
foundations of physics
right it's not that everybody has to you
know Spotlight but it's really a
worthwhile
subject matter for physicists to think
about foundational issues and to me this
is just wonderful because that's I mean
I know people I mean I was lucky because
I'm in the philosophy community and
philosophers are happy with the
questions I'm interested in
but physicists trying to do foundational
work
you know I mean they have a very very
very very very hard time just at a
practical level because it's not valued
it's just not valued in physics
departments it's considered somehow
illegitimate do you see Consciousness as
a foundational question
Consciousness I see is the hardest
question there is
I I think the mind-body problem is the
hardest
conundrum on hard and that's because you
can't even imagine what a solution could
look like right
right I I don't understand I don't know
I just could I mean if you sort of think
I'm going to give an example if you go
back to ancient Greece and they said I
wonder what matters made of and the
atomists
say well I think it's these little hard
atoms and all they can do is move and
some of them have hooks and some of them
have eyes and sometimes they hook
together and you know okay
you can at least understand
in a sketchy way how such an a postulate
could account for tables and chairs and
things burning and you know okay they
become unhooked or they get hooked or
blah blah blah I mean at least you see
maybe it's wrong maybe it's completely
off Target it turned out it was off
Target but I mean that's story but at
least you could see from the beginning
how if it were true
it could account for what you want
accounted for which is the behavior of
objects at macroscopic scale
in the case of Consciousness I don't
even know what a solution to the Mind
Body problem could look like
without putting any other constraints I
just don't know
essentially what you're asking for is
some Physics
that when you apply it to a physical
body
in the structural form of a human brain
or a dog's brain or you know I don't
know an ant's brain I'm not sure right I
don't know are ants conscious I don't
know
that somehow you see that gee that
physical Behavior would be accompanied
by or create or whatever
a subjective State like pain
and I don't understand how that could be
so I think that's the hardest problem
there is and because it's so hard I
don't work on it because I don't even
understand what a solution would look
like I mean I I've pointed out
one of the first papers I published was
a paper called computation and
Consciousness which is just pointing out
that a certain kind of attempt to answer
that question can't be right
but I don't know what the right answer
is I don't even know I I I'm you know
so I it's not that I don't think there's
a problem there it's I think there's a
problem there that's so intractable yes
that I don't want to spend my time
banging my head against a brick wall now
I firmly believe I'm not a duelist I
firmly believe
that anybody who had a brain
that was physically identical to mine
and the neurons and everything were
doing things physically identical to
mine they would be having conscious
experiences that would be qualitatively
identical to mine
so I'm not a duelist
I think that Consciousness in some sense
supervenes on physical activity because
I think that's all I am I'm ultimately a
physical thing
uh it therefore depends on quantum
mechanics just because physics depends
on quantum mechanics but I I I don't see
I don't see
any clue
of
a comprehensible account of why
subjective physical States should
accompany any sort of physical activity
so you know you work where you think you
can make progress and you just you know
you acknowledge where you don't think
you can and where there are problems
um you mentioned that you ruled out a
certain class of Consciousness theories
that are computational yeah I don't know
if that was the correct wording
regardless can you expound on that is
this similar to the Penrose Lucas
argument there's a whole there's a whole
class of theories that that are called
functionalists
and the basic idea is
what makes a system conscious is kind of
independent of the particular physical
stuff it's made of it's rather how that
physical stuff behaves
um functions in a certain way
this is sorry is this the same as
substrate Independence or no yeah it's a
sort of kind of a substrate Independence
right that that's a that's a kind of
General class
uh then in that General class there's a
much more specific
realization of it that's called
computationism that says what's really
important is to understand
what computations the system is doing
where I then understand a computation in
terms of a turing machine turntable
right using turrets way of understanding
a computation okay
so such a theory would be committed to
saying that any system
that there's some calculation or some
computation
on some input that can be done such that
any system doing that computation on
that input will be conscious in a
certain way
all right let's see and again by
conscious I mean the Paradigm cases of
is pain right have a toothache right any
any system that satisfies a certain
touring table performing a certain
computation on a certain input will
experience subjectively a two thing
and what I have as an argument is that
that can't be right because you can
implement the turing machine table
in Peculiar ways and not ways that
anybody would actually do in Practical
life but theoretically you can implement
a turing machine in ways
that
the deterring description depends on a
bunch of structure that's not physically
active
through a certain period it's physically
completely inert it's not doing anything
and according to this whether that
structure is there or not will determine
whether there's a toothache but on the
other hand you can see that whether that
stuff is there or not makes absolutely
no physical difference to the it makes
no difference to the physical activity
going on
so if you think that the conscious State
really is determined by physical
activity it shows that this
computational
conceptual apparatus is the wrong one to
be bringing to you
but that you can read that paper I mean
it's a journal philosophy will you be
able to send me the title of it so I can
include it in the description it's
called computation and Consciousness it
was published in general philosophy
I mean I could pull up my CV I think
it's 1989 but you can find it I'll leave
a link to it in the description so does
that include
formulations like integrated information
Theory that's not well not exactly
because because as I understand it the
IIT idea involves
uh uh information theoretic Concepts
that go beyond touring the Turing
description
but on the other hand I know Scott
Aronson's criticisms of the IIT and I
find them completely convincing so I
don't think the IIT has any more hope
uh of being an account of Consciousness
than the term Michigan stuff does have
you heard of the global neuronal
workspace Theory
I the the the the words
are a little familiar to me but I don't
know it in a way in any detail to be
able to comment intelligently about it
have you heard of yosha Bach yoshibak
who has his computational
Consciousness model I don't know what
it's called uh yeah I'm afraid I'm all
right don't worry about that okay what
are your opinions on wolfram's physics
theory because it's entirely
computational and seems to at least he
believes it produces Consciousness
because we're here and he believes his
theory to be correct have you taken a
look into his physics project
um again not not not in any detail I
mean
so I tend to you know anybody who says
the foundations are computation again it
seems computation is just the wrong
concept to be bringing to physics why
because
it's because computers have the physical
structure they have that they're capable
of doing the computations that they're
capable of doing
that is the physics determines the
computational structure not the other
way around
so you know some somebody I mean it it
it's a bit in the ballpark of
uh uh uh of again the the idea that
everything is mathematical right so all
physical reality is just mathematical
Max tegmark's idea I just it's so far
so far off base to me that I don't
really feel like I need to spend a lot
of time on them
you know I think the physical world you
know I don't know space time it's got
particles it's got Fields it's got some
Quantum State trying to understand how
all that stuff fits together trying to
figure out what the what the small scale
geometry of the physical spaces and
space time and this all strikes me as as
recognizable
speculative physics but you go beyond a
certain point and I don't even recognize
it as specular
okay so let's just get to a couple
questions on time there's entropic time
and then there's thermal time I don't
know if those two are the same but what
are your views on those explanations is
to the arrow outside I don't I don't I I
don't even understand I mean again I
have to just be I don't understand even
what that means there's time okay
there's there's a variable we normally
designated with a t
um when we assign numbers to it we tend
to assign numbers so that as
time goes forward the numbers get larger
um
to say that there's entropic time I
don't even understand what that means I
mean it's true that if a system is not
at its entropic maximum it's not thermal
that typically as time goes forward it
will become closer to
thermal equilibrium
um
that that
that's a fact about about and and we
understand why that's so I mean there's
pretty good statistical understanding of
of why as time goes forward entropy
tends to increase but I don't think that
means there's a new kind of time there's
just time
I think what's being indicated is that
entropy is the reason for the direction
of time yeah so I think that's
completely I mean is that anything that
makes any I mean look if the universe
eventually which it it could in some
models
if it comes to thermal equilibrium
and so there's no entropy gradient the
entropy is just reaches its maximum and
stays there at least for a very long
time it's still the case that that the
time is going from the past to the
future I mean time will still go on
why why would anyone think
that the time would cease to I mean
the state would constantly be changing I
mean if you're a thermal equilibrium
things are still changing right I mean a
gas in a box comes to equilibrium it's
microstate is still changing all the
time and its change is a normal change
from past to Future and uh the causal
structure is that is that you know these
two particles bounced off each other and
therefore all that goes on even though
even though there's no entropy gradient
I mean why would why why would anyone
even postulate that uh the passage of
time depends upon an entropy gradient
it's the other way around
right the passage of time explains
together with certain statistical
considerations
why typically in a predictably entropy
goes up if it has a place to go
up
um
but that doesn't make time depend on
entropy it makes entropy depend on time
someone that people keep referencing to
me to look up is Henry bergson and then
they say that bergson and Bohm
knew each other or had or or they
developed their theories together or
where they were influential to one
another
so now that I know that you're an
extreme bomb fan or at least you're
you're a proponent of the pilot wave
theory what are your thoughts on Burks
and I read I read a book about Burks and
and Einstein I think you know bergson
was tremendously confused I I wouldn't I
wouldn't recommend anybody to spend time
reading bergson and quite honestly I
wouldn't recommend anybody spend a lot
of time reading
the kinds of things bone wrote in the
60s when he got involved with
krishnamurti and he becomes kind of
semi-mystical and there's the in quick
inquick order and I mean he wrote a
bunch of kind of weird stuff
um you know for you you you you you you
want to look at his 1952 papers and then
even better we'll get Belle's
presentation of the theory which as I
say bone presents it in terms of a thing
called a Quantum potential and using
Newtonian Dynamics and that's a bad idea
it's not really a Newtonian Theory
um it's a great Theory okay and it was
also again a theory that already de
broily had seen it's the theory is kind
of
almost inevitable way to understand
quantum theory once you ask questions in
a certain way
um
but you know poor boom I mean he got he
got
attacked for political reasons in the
United States kind of exiled to you know
he had a a life that was you know one of
being rejected
having been at Princeton and having
talked to to Einstein and having been
influenced by Einstein and then he ends
up you know in Brazil and then
eventually at the LSA I have a lot of
Sympathy for the man as a human being
um but I think it made him his rejection
by the physics community
uh made him more
open to align with like krishnamurti and
some people who were of a more mystical
Bend
uh and I personally I I don't I don't I
don't I I don't like I don't see
anything in that that's helpful helpful
for for me to do physics
so I would say study the theory
um I mean the he he wrote this later
book called The undivided universe and
there's some useful things in that
together with the
Holland or not anyway
um but but I I wouldn't get too wrapped
up in bone the individual because he was
he I mean he was quite unless you're
just interested in it as a personality I
think a lot of the peculiarities of him
as a personality don't are not useful
for understanding physics
did you ever get to meet Belle sure yeah
I met him uh three four times
what was that like oh he's he was just
he was just the most wonderful human
being I mean completely unpretentious
completely open
completely uh I mean
I'll tell you a story well I mean I I
did meet him through and unfortunately
he was supposed to come to Rutgers when
I was there uh and he died about a week
before he was supposed to come which was
a great tragedy for us but I I met him
uh at a philosophy of science
association meeting but not really
talked to him there I met him in Arisha
at a meeting and I met him at Rutgers he
came to Rutgers before and talked to him
individually
um but an interesting thing happened
I'll just tell you a story because it
it's so much to me Belle the first time
I heard I mentioned this Girardi Romiti
Weber Theory
which is an objective collapse Theory
and Bell
has a paper called are there Quantum
jumps which is again in this book
um which is his presentation of the grw
theory
uh although he goes beyond in certain
ways what they did
um but a very nice presentation and the
first time I heard about that theory was
from Belle himself it was in oriche
at this uh NATO summer school
and I was somebody who grew up
with the common idea that okay there are
these collapses of the wave function and
they're associated with measurements and
measurements are associated with
Consciousness this kind of idea you
associate with with Eugene vigner
and therefore oh this is amazing this is
where consciousness
connects with physics right that
Consciousness collapses the wave
function and so on so you think the most
important question there could be is
what triggers these collapses
and Bell presents the grw theory and the
thing is in that theory nothing triggers
them they just happen at random with
fixed probability per unit time per
particle there's no environmental
trigger there's no anything they just
happen okay they just happen at random
um and and so Bell gives this talk and I
went up to him afterwards and I said I
said you're satisfied with this Theory I
mean here we've been for years and years
worried about what causes these
collapses what causes these collapses
and their answers it just happens and
and you're happy with that and he just
he was so mild I mean I can't express to
you what a nice man he was and he was so
mild and he just kind of smiled and he
just looked at me and he said you don't
appreciate what they've done
and he was absolutely right and there
was no point arguing with me at that
moment but he said exactly the right
thing
what they did was they took this idea of
a collapse and gave it a precise
mathematical formulation
and so they turned a notion into an
actual physical Theory
whether you like it or not I mean there
are things about the theory one could
dislike even Girardi who I got to know
quite well
never thought it was a final theory
always thought it was a kind of
transition point to a better Theory but
they managed to just write down some
equations
not mentioned measurement not mentioned
observers and get a theory that gave you
basically the right predictions
so Belle was like that and and he didn't
you know he was just always tremendously
on point on target
but he wasn't he just seemed to be the
nicest person in the world I mean after
he died there was a there was a eulogy
session for him at the philosophy of
science Association I remember Phil
Pearl who had been working also on
objective production theories continuous
ones
you know he he got up and he said for
him
Bell you know for he was somebody Phil
was somebody working on these
foundational issues and he said for him
it was like Belle was kind of a knight
on a ski to protect them right I mean he
was the guy they're doing things that
are very unpopular in the physics
community and they could always count on
Belle
to be there to kind of protect them and
to say you're doing you know what you're
doing is important
um and yeah and you know you think the
guy I mean he was a very down to earth
guy he was an engine I'm a century an
engineer he was designing magnets at
CERN and he was doing all of this
foundational work literally on his
weekends and when he had a sabbatical
you know he wasn't paid to do it
but he had
a a tremendously sharp mind and he had a
tremendous
physical intuition right what the
physical world and Einstein talked about
having a kind of
um empathetic understanding of the
physical world I mean you felt like
Belle had that he he wasn't satisfied
with doing a calculation right he wanted
to understand what was going on you get
that feeling out of fine when you
refinement too right that he he just
driving something mathematically that
wasn't enough he wanted a picture he
wanted you know he wanted a feel of what
the physics was really about
um and he was just you know a
tremendously kind and Mild person in
real life I mean
you really can't say enough about it
Professor thank you for spending so much
time with me
thank you I mean it's been been fun
um I hope it was
more or less what you were looking for
but it was more it was more thank you
all right well I do have a side question
how do you keep your mind Sharp
you may say well my mind is a sharp it's
dull but how is it that I don't think
that you have a dull mind so I imagine
you have some practice maybe it's
running maybe it's read maybe you have a
certain ritual I mean look what I do
that actually has an influence on that I
I don't know for sure I mean I I know
from the little I read that some of the
things I do like crosswords actually
don't make any difference all right yeah
so people say if you do this and this
and this and then they think well no
actually and and of course people do say
that exercise makes a difference and I
do try to get a reasonable amount of
exercise maybe that helps I I don't know
I you know don't have the empirical
basis to tell you
there was a question about Judea Pearl
because he has a book on causation I
wanted to ask you apparently you have
some objections to his but if it's too
long then we'll save it for the next
time if we speak again yeah I mean look
it I mean there's a funny thing about
Pearl if you're interested in Pearl I
should just mention uh it's relevant to
understanding
is it what Pearl's doing is is uh
is both similar to and was influenced by
work that my dissertation director Clark
gleimore did together with Richard
shyness and Kevin Kelly on on causal on
causal modeling and and causal discovery
um
and uh
and I just kind of have a feeling that
that that Pearl gets more attention for
that relative to what he did and what
they did that is is warranted
um
so I'm a little I mean I'm a little bit
I don't want to say defensive but I I do
like if you wanted to look into it you
should look into gleimore's work
um
which was some of it earlier than pearls
and and again Pearl really learned
some of the some of the techniques from
them
um so it's not a criticism of his work
it's more about the attribution yeah
there's a there's a bit of there's a bit
about attribution
um there there's some stuff that he does
in his book if you read I mean I have
this review of this more popular book
you probably saw that right in the in
the Boston Review
and there is some stuff there that I
just disagree with it's not the
technical stuff it's this you know this
this kind of more hand wavy stuff
um the technical stuff is just writing
down causal graphs and uh representing
various interventions and then seeing
what kind of Statistics you should you
should expect in different experimental
situations uh given different causal
structures and all that I don't I don't
have any objection to I mean it's but it
is very it is the same thing more or
less that uh that Queen
all right hey thank you again and I I
appreciate it tremendously
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to
theoriesofeverything.org it's support
from the patrons and from the sponsors
that allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you